Do Do,
do
and we're live.
Ladies and gentlemen with status.
Russell pretended to be a morning Dj.
Alright.
Hey,
how liberally going out there in the
wild and wacky world of being a
professor?
I got to leave.
Sorry.
You gotta leave.
We can't do this.
You didn't get fired since last time?
Not yet.
That's good.
I'm trying hard.
Are you being on here?
Sure.
Doesn't help.
It doesn't.
Did you get any heat at all?
Yeah,
it did actually.
What'd you get heat about it?
Oh God.
Here we go.
Uh,
I uh,
know someone complained about the
podcast.
One person,
someone who was raised,
someone who was referenced in that,
but not,
not by name,
but someone who is referenced.
Oh,
like one of the people that we
complained about,
someone complained to the administration
about what we talked about.
Oh my goodness.
And what did they say?
Nothing was done to me.
I don't know.
I was just told that there was a
complaint made.
So how does that work?
Did they have to examine every complaint
for a severely?
They did not.
They didn't pay us.
Yeah,
I was totally,
it was a formal complaint,
but then nothing,
as far as I know it was done about it.
So I'm still there,
although I'm probably leaving Occidental
anyway.
Oh my goodness.
Is this a news flash?
Uh,
yeah,
it is actually.
I guess I breaking news.
Yeah.
I might be taking a new position at
Willamette University in Oregon.
Oh,
but you got to move up there and I'm
going to split time between Lin and
they're,
oh,
you're a glutton for punishment.
Yeah,
my son,
my son is here,
so I got to,
yeah,
that's how long commute isn't that?
Well,
actually hours in a plane.
You know,
it's funny.
It's like an hour and a half and then
it's about the same as what I'm doing
now between the east side of La and the
west side of la where,
where his mother lives.
Um,
so actually it's not that much
different.
Different commute for me.
Oh,
the traffic versus the flight?
Yeah.
I mean,
I haven't done it yet,
so we'll see.
But I think it'll work out.
Wow.
What an optimistic fellow you are.
I Love Oregon though.
It's all so beautiful.
And they have water,
they have much water of water and they
have green plants.
Everything's green.
It's incredibly great.
Yeah,
it's,
it's an interesting trade off.
It's like they get a lot of rain,
but because of that,
the,
the grass is like this vibrant,
almost like glowing Greens.
Like the opposite of La.
Yeah.
Everything's alive and lush.
It gets a little dreary though.
Like when you don't see the son,
I'm worried about like February,
March,
April.
But I've heard the summers are great.
The summers are amazing.
Same as Seattle.
Like I was just in Seattle recently and
it rained three days in a row and by the
time the third day rolled around we were
like,
okay,
let's get out of here.
Exactly.
It was fun cause you know,
I was visiting some friends and I was
with my family,
so [inaudible] took the kids and they're
just love the fact that it's different,
you know,
because it never rains out here.
They're like,
Yay.
You get to go play splashing in puddles
and running around.
Yeah.
But if that's every day,
you're like,
oh look,
the 90th day in a row they've had,
I think they had like a flip of rain in
the last month they've had a,
but last winter they had like an
incredibly dry winter and it was
amazing.
Yeah.
No,
but I'm looking forward to it because
you know,
I love hiking and camping in the
mountains and the ocean and all that
stuff.
That's a great spot to be grounded by
it.
Yeah.
And you say it's Willamette?
Willamette?
We'll laminate and Sam Salem,
which is just south of Portland.
Oh,
okay.
Wow.
That's awesome.
That's great country up there.
Yeah.
So a,
would that,
was that part of the incentive to get
you to go there?
Well,
the deal is my,
my partner or girlfriend got a job as a
vice president there.
Partner slash girlfriend,
partner,
girlfriend.
I don't know.
I hate that.
There's no good term for it right now.
You're seeing that your special lady
friends were married?
You know,
before I was married,
I'd call my wife,
my special lady friend.
But yeah,
sometimes I call her my lady,
but I can't do that on the campus.
You know what I mean?
Like you can get in trouble for that.
I get totally in trouble.
Yeah.
How hilarious is that?
Well,
since you've been here,
the uh,
social justice warrior,
yeah.
Crusade has ramped up considerably.
Um,
including what happened in Yale,
uh,
with the woman who she,
I guess she sent out a letter saying
that you should allow people a certain
amount of leeway to be offensive.
Like you shouldn't,
we shouldn't restrict what kind of
costumes kids can wear,
including if they want to wear things
that are,
that appropriate other cultures and
things along those lines.
So you should give people the
opportunity to be offensive,
I think is what she said.
Right.
Um,
I,
I guess opening up the door for free
expression,
the idea is that you're supposed to be
learning in these schools.
You're supposed to be exploring
different ways of thinking and whether
or not something is of,
is this a,
is this humorous?
Is is valid in our culture or is it not?
Should you be offended?
Is it pointless to be offended?
Is it silly?
Does it offend everyone?
If it doesn't offend people who it's
supposed to be culturally appropriating,
then what's,
what's it on you?
So it was this opening up this can of
worms,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
It's a can of worms.
It's a very complex issue.
I mean,
it is a lot to unpack here.
So first of all,
I don't know if you know,
she quit for good.
Yes.
That professor,
I believe her husband did as well,
right?
The Dean,
the Dean of Silliman College.
I didn't think so.
Okay.
I could be wrong.
Um,
so yeah,
it's been all over the country.
It's been very intense at Occidental,
by the way.
Yeah.
And I've been in meetings and I've seen
a lot of it there.
I've been sort of in the middle of it.
Um,
it's a,
it's a complete cluster fuck.
There's no doubt about that.
I mean,
that's,
that's my scholarly opinion.
It is really,
it's,
it's gone to the level of being a
caricature of political correctness,
Pcu,
the movie you've ever seen,
that it's really,
it really often looks like that.
Yeah.
It's like a south park episode,
almost a South Park episode.
It really is to the level of caricature
now.
Um,
and so,
you know,
obviously a lot of what the student
protesters are saying is hysteria.
I mean they talk as if they're in
Alabama in 1960 when they're actually at
Yale or Occidental college and they are
among the most privileged people on the
planet,
right?
Just by being there.
Um,
and uh,
many of their demands are essentially
totalitarian,
you know,
demanding diversity training,
mandatory diversity training for all
faculty and staff,
which,
you know,
I'm assuming would be teaching me how to
think about race and gender and
sexuality,
right.
Telling me what I should should say in
my classrooms and not say in my
classrooms.
Um,
that Occidental,
the faculty themselves,
some of the faculty,
I actually took it upon themselves to
propose,
uh,
a mechanism in which students can report
micro aggressions committed against them
by five faculty.
The faculty,
the students didn't even demand this.
How is this happening?
I will say,
just to be clear here,
it hasn't been voted.
The faculty hasn't voted for that yet,
but it was a significant minority of
faculty propose that significant like
30% probably around there.
Yeah,
I'd say about a third to a,
a mechanism to report microaggressions.
Microaggressions.
Meaning like,
Oh,
90 shirt.
Well,
I could look at you and go,
nice shirt.
We can be specific because they've
actually listed micro aggressions in
many places and one of them is asking
the question,
where are you from?
Oh my God.
Oh God,
that's a microaggression.
Where are you from?
Is One way.
Uh,
another one is what are you all right,
what are you
following up with?
What are you really well,
what are you seems like a good question
today because you have to be really
careful with gender pronouns.
Indeed.
So why can't you just say,
what are you,
what are you doesn't seem offensive at
all.
Could be you could be a g j uh,
she,
uhZ,
,
I'm not even sure how it's pronounced,
but,
but when someone says,
what are you like,
I think that that's gender neutral.
So that's actually should be politically
correct.
Oh yeah.
But it's not race neutral.
Oh,
okay.
So it's a question about race,
right?
But why is it a question about race?
You're like a Mulatto Looking,
oh mama say Mulatto and don't think
you'll have a similar story from 1971
it's not good.
No,
but I don't even believe it's,
it shouldn't be mixed race because
you're,
you're a human,
you know,
it's all one race that's been proven
scientifically.
It could.
The question is what race are you?
Which is sort of a silly question and a
little bit terrible question.
Slightly rude.
Sure.
But it's also like scientifically
invalid.
Yeah.
Because there's only one race.
It might be different ethnicities,
different parts of the world where your
ancestors and different cultures,
but he's the only one race.
Like this idea of what's your race?
It's fucking stupid.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But so that's,
but that's considered to be that kind of
ignorance is considered to be violent.
And I mean that violence,
hostile racism,
because the refresh,
the refrain is we are unsafe on this
campus.
That's,
that's the word that's used.
If someone says,
what are you doing?
You become unsafe.
Yes,
I am.
That's not an exaggeration.
Sure.
That's exactly what it said guys with
hoods and yeah,
so,
right,
so coaches,
there's this incredible conflation that
goes on,
which drives me insane because certainly
there is some racism on campuses.
You know,
there is some racial insensitivity,
no doubt,
but they conflate that stuff that goes
on at Yale with Ferguson and Baltimore
and Birmingham,
Alabama in 1956 and South Africa under
apartheid,
right?
It all becomes the same thing,
It all becomes white supremacy.
It's all racism.
It's all structural racism.
It's all systemic racism.
Uh,
and so we need to start sort of
differentiating here cause there's
clearly some differences among those.
So what are you as one,
what are you really is the followup,
which is like the death where you
doubled down on your racism.
Um,
what are some other ones?
So it would make me feel like a double
micro aggression,
but it's the mother one.
Um,
where are you from?
Who are,
what are you?
Um,
well then there's things,
you know,
that there's things that clearly are
rude,
possibly racist,
like you're really smart or you're
really articulate to a black person.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait,
wait.
Why?
What if he's really articulate?
What if he talking to a woman and she's
black and she's super articulate and you
know,
wow,
you're really articulate.
Or whether you're talking to a white man
and he's really articulate and go,
wow,
you're really articulate.
As I said,
it might be racist,
but it might just be a compliment.
Well,
it's just that,
that's what's often been said.
I mean,
you have to understand.
I do often been said,
you know,
remember what Joe Biden said about Obama
during the election,
right?
He said he's very,
the people like him,
cause he's so articulate and well
spoken,
right?
It's,
it's what's classically been said,
but why is that racist?
That's just show model black people.
Why is that racist?
Because you're comparing him to the
former president,
George W.
Bush was totally the opposite of that
was not right.
He was terrible at it.
So when you get a guy like Obama,
he's clearly articulate,
intelligent,
right?
Why is that racist at all?
Well,
again,
it's because it's been said about the
model black person.
Right?
Uh,
but unless you use it in that context,
unless you say as a black guy,
he's very articulate.
Right?
Which has been said to you on campuses.
You know,
and often they'll say things like,
to a black guy in particular,
oh,
you must be an athlete.
You must be on a sports team.
Um,
what if they're yoked yet?
Well,
with their black higher and the fucking,
you know,
right.
They could just like Lebron James,
Physics major lifts a lot of weights
though.
Come on,
Jay could be,
but I mean,
why is that a bad thing to say you,
you must be really good moving your
body.
It's footing it.
Annoy you.
It wouldn't.
No,
you wouldn't.
It.
What if somebody asks you if you were
black and someone said that to you,
oh,
you're here because you must be on the
floor.
Okay.
Well if it was that,
if it was like the insinuation that the
only reason why you got into the college
was because of your athletic prowess,
not your intelligence,
what it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
That these things are not completely
groundless.
It's not,
it's mostly
hysteria.
I see what you're saying.
There is a lot that's legitimate.
That's real.
That I understand that I have compassion
for,
I've never been a black person.
I've never been a black college student,
but I've always been sure that it must
be at least uncomfortable for black
people on the,
on these campuses that are mostly white.
Yeah.
In some circumstances for sure.
Well that makes sense.
But I mean it seems like socially that
stuff all weeds itself out.
Like people realize who the decks are
and you avoid those people.
They said we were talking about like the
word microaggression is suitable for
that and that is a micro aggression.
It's so micro,
it's all like,
it's this kind of slightly dicky.
Right.
And so the question is do you have a
macro response to a micro grid in its
form of policy,
which limits freedom of speech?
Which limits academic freedom,
which you rex the surveillance system.
Right.
Essentially,
which is essentially what they're asking
for with microaggressions.
Uh,
limits,
humor to it certainly limits humor.
It eliminates,
well,
you know,
college campuses,
there's no,
there's no fun being had.
I mean there's no end though.
Funniness right.
It's a,
it's in fact,
I was just talking about this with
someone the other night.
They said,
well,
you guys are crack a lot of jokes.
I said,
no,
there are no,
there no jobs.
They used to be like animal house.
No,
I mean I do,
I do joke in my classroom,
but sort of the space outside of the
classroom on campus,
sort of in public arenas on campus.
No,
you've gotta be really dour and earnest
all the time.
Oh God.
It's so tiresome.
It certainly is,
but that's not life.
Now.
What are they preparing people for?
That's the thing.
Right.
Um,
you know,
so I mean,
what if you're going to,
John mcwhorter is this brilliant black
Columbia linguistics professor.
Micro microaggression.
Yeah.
Right?
I say black.
I did,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
to him and everyone,
he has said that when he was in college
in the 1980s,
he heard a few times statements that
were clearly racist that we're even sort
of hostile and racist eating.
They're not no doubt about it.
He said,
but he said it never occurred to me that
I might be damaged by that.
That it might hurt me to hear these
things.
I just assumed that these people were
worthless when they said it.
That they're like gum on my shoe.
Yeah,
exactly right.
So what's happening now is kids on
campuses either have been trained or
have trained themselves to feel damaged.
Devastated is the word actually that's
often used by things like micro
aggressions.
Hmm.
Well,
so that what you're doing is you are
stating and claiming status as a weak
person,
right?
Someone who can be damaged by the
slightest.
Slight.
Right?
So then what happens when you're in the
real world where there really are
racists,
where there really are people who will
pull you over for being black,
who will throw him in prison for being
black,
who will shoot you for being black,
who will not give you a job for black,
you know,
real racism,
real structural racism.
What do you do then?
Well,
I think the idea is that they're going
to eliminate that by raising people
through their system that never have
these thoughts.
Um,
so we're gonna clean up the world.
If that were a plan,
at least it would be a plan.
I don't see that as the plan though.
Well,
the professional victim status,
that that's a real issue because people
claiming to be victims when there is no
real problem.
They're looking for victims.
They're looking for,
rather,
we're looking for things that are
targeting them.
And I always assumed that the reason why
people do that is because there's not
enough real problems.
The real problems have become so minute.
Like this is the safest time to live
ever.
And on campus.
I mean,
outside of the normal things that you're
going to deal with when you have a bunch
of young people together and you know,
uh,
social interactions and alcohol and all
the other crap that happens between
human beings,
when you get them together in a young,
and they don't have,
even when they're older,
you know,
you get a group of people together,
you're likely to have some disputes.
But outside of that,
what's the fucking worst thing that's
happening in these kids?
I think I actually looked up the
statistics because I,
you know,
people during,
when the Missouri thing was happening at
the University of Missouri,
right?
Yes.
Claims about,
you know,
nigger being said and you know,
racist violence in there.
And I thought,
really,
is that possible?
So I looked it up.
I mean,
there's not,
there has not been a,
a racist hate crime on a college campus
in the United States in 30 years.
Wow.
And in fact,
in that one,
which was in the early,
uh,
30 years ago was a guy who wasn't a
student.
He wasn't affiliated with the campus at
all with the college at all.
Who bombed some dormitory that had black
people in it.
So basically it's,
yes,
of course it is an extremely safe place
to be.
And everyone don't you think that in
those extremely safe environments,
sometimes people just go around looking
for problems that don't exist?
Well,
I mean,
this has been the case at an American
colleges for decades.
I mean,
when I was in college in the 1980s,
that's all we did.
We,
we needed to fight the devil we needed
to.
And then,
then you had to find the devil.
And the problem was he wasn't there.
Right.
The Ku Klux Klan wasn't actually on
campus.
Right.
The police weren't even really on
campus.
You know,
you didn't have these terrible sexist
and racist on campus,
so you had to invent them.
And what you did was you invented them
in the form of the president of the
college often.
Right.
He became the villain that you had to
attack.
Right.
And I did that.
Um,
and that's what's going on now.
So the,
one of the main demands of students at
Occidental was the resignation of the
president.
Why?
What did he do wrong?
It's a great question and I haven't
actually gotten a specific answer to
that.
There's no answer cause he a white guy.
Yeah.
Well fuck him.
Well he embodies privilege.
Of course he does.
Uh,
but everyone at Occidental and buddy's
privileged,
everyone does.
Right?
Everyone at Yale and bodies privilege.
Right.
Of course.
Will students as faculty of luck,
Asca,
Filipino peasant,
you know what they think of student
yells at students at Yale,
whether they're privileged or not,
right?
Yes.
Um,
so does it have specific trees?
A tremendous lack of specificity,
which also drives me crazy.
Um,
I often say,
I don't even know what they're talking
about.
I be,
and I don't know what's happened to
them.
What has he actually done?
So there's been a demand for a black
studies program at Occidental for
decades,
since the 60s.
Okay.
So that hasn't been instituted.
But you know,
he's only the most recent president who
hasn't done that.
And by the way,
it's a faculty decision anyway,
whether I have a black studies program.
Other than that,
I couldn't even tell you.
I really couldn't tell you.
It's so racial charge kind of.
It's also about the sexual assault
stuff.
But the sexual assault stuff was so
bizarre and also lacking in specificity
there.
They're being sued by the young man who
was accused of sexual assault while the
woman that he had sex with was not.
Yes.
And the reason why he was accused of
being,
of being the assaulter,
it's cause he's a male.
Well,
they were both drinking,
but that's the only,
that's the only conclusion you could
draw for.
People don't know the story.
You can google the story.
It's fascinating.
And we talked about it the last time we
were here.
Um,
but,
uh,
a man and a woman,
because they're both over 18,
they were going to college there.
They,
uh,
got liquored up and decided to hook up
and they exchanged some text messages
where she said,
do you have condoms?
Come on over.
And she told her friend,
I'm going to have sex,
lol,
that kind of thing.
And uh,
after they had sex,
someone either convinced her or she
convinced herself that it was rape.
Because when two people are drinking,
the woman cannot.
Consent was the only time in the world
where you're not responsible for your
actions because you've been drinking.
If you get in a car and you drank and
you drive drunk and plow into people,
you can never say,
I'm not responsible because I was drunk
and he can't say that.
But for whatever reason,
these social justice warriors have taken
upon themselves to,
again,
in part victim status only on women that
are in these scenarios.
So that the man is always the ugly
oppressor,
the ugly pursuer,
the penetrator of the vagina is evil
man.
And so this kid got kicked out of
college for having sex while drunk.
That's really what it is.
The most outrageous thing was at the
college itself actually officially
determined that the sex was consensual.
Yeah.
But he got expelled.
And he's suing now.
He should fucking close that place down.
Yeah.
And then light it on fire and turn it to
Disneyland too.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think a revolution is coming or it's
maybe already begun in higher education,
you know?
Wow.
Well,
I think what we're doing right now,
I think what you've been doing,
I think stuff like this,
I think podcasting,
I think,
uh,
it started with blogs 20 years ago now.
There's all sorts of online courses.
I think there's a tremendous demand for
learning and I think there are a lot of
curious people out there who can't
afford to go to college or don't want to
go to these nut houses that are
colleges.
But what is it that's causing these not
houses to,
to
flourish this way where it's so common.
It's not an oddity.
It's not just dartmouth where they
stormed into the library or the,
uh,
the study hall and started screaming
black lives matter while fucking white
and black people were going over their
work.
They're sitting there trying to do their
homework and all these fucking white
dorks are running through the hallway
screen.
Black lives matter,
black lives matter.
And I'm watching that.
I'm going,
why is this like these people aren't
oppressors,
the,
their,
their students or fellow students,
like,
and you're being shamed if you don't
join in,
you're being shamed if you don't stop
whatever you're doing.
What is this?
How is this happening?
It's so difficult to unpack.
Well,
so here's it actually.
It actually stems from a sort of
sophisticated social theory,
which is that discourse can be violence.
That discourse is power and discourse
can therefore be violence.
Just stay with me.
I know.
Um,
and so if discourse is violence than any
means are necessary to defend oneself
from discursive violence.
Oh boy.
Right?
And then on top of that,
and I agree with this part,
I mean silence can be discourse to,
right,
right.
So sure.
Silence in the case of these kids in the
Dartmouth Library,
right,
was violence.
If you carry that argument to its
logical extreme,
which is what obviously is happening
here,
it's a perversion of French
poststructuralism,
which made this intervention about 40
years ago about discourse being power
and,
and also being violence.
So that's,
they're kind of running with the idea.
And if you run with it all the way,
it becomes totalitarian.
Right.
And then you're back in like Maoist
China.
Uh,
because everyone who says the wrong
thing or doesn't say the right thing is
a criminal is an enemy and must be dealt
with by any means necessary.
Oh
yeah.
No,
it's bad.
It's bad.
Now,
the good news is that right now these
people don't have much power.
Right.
They aren't right now these kids aren't
running congress.
The bad news is that they will be
running America pretty soon,
but isn't the good news is that with
time and maturity and life experiences,
they'll become like you.
One would hope we're like them.
Yes.
I was.
One would hope,
and that's it's probably true to some
extent.
However,
I don't know if you know about this,
but there's been some recent polling
done of millennials by the Pew Research
Organization and they found that
millennials are much more hostile to the
principle of free speech than previous
generations.
Yeah.
I saw that the students in Yale,
actually,
there was a significant majority voted
to resend the first amendment.
Yup.
Yeah.
No,
no.
What is this?
What is that,
Jay?
We,
do you know what that one is that that
that study,
they,
I think it was like 39% or something.
Some,
yeah.
Saying amounts about,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they're really,
they state
regulation of speech.
That is so crazy.
Not a majority,
I don't think,
but a hefty minority of millennials do
in a larger,
a larger portion of them than any other
generation,
whatever.
40% of millennials.
Okay.
With limiting speech defenses to mind
there in minorities.
Hefty minority.
There you go.
But do they understand like what,
what the state is,
so that's really depressing.
That's something to be afraid of.
Yeah,
because these are the people that,
as I said,
they have no institutional power now,
but they will.
They will.
Yeah.
These are,
these are kids in elite colleges who
believe this.
Right?
What do you,
what,
what do you think those elite colleges
do?
They train people to take power people.
It's like,
well,
if you asked anyone,
no one thinks that you should say rude
things to minorities.
No one thinks you should say offensive
things to anybody.
No one thinks that.
But when you decide what is offensive
and what you shouldn't,
shouldn't say,
you limit discourse,
you,
you have power over other people's
ability to express themselves and you,
you,
what you do is you create these splinter
groups where people get off together and
they fucking,
they closed the blinds and go,
yeah,
all right,
now it's time to talk about Mexico.
Exactly.
And they get together and they say
racist shit and the Fintech groups,
right?
So you can,
you can see it like in comments sections
on the web,
right?
You can see it and read it and you can
see it anywhere.
There's a novice users on the,
on the Internet,
right?
That's what repression does.
I mean,
there's like clearly hardcore racism and
sexism and misogyny and rape culture in
those corners.
Yes.
It's all anonymous.
Right?
And these are,
these are the repressed,
this is the repressed talking.
Yes.
That's what happens.
Right?
And um,
so yeah,
but it's also,
I think it's even worse than this,
right?
Because as I said the last time I was
here,
you know,
it's,
it is inherently conservative what
they're calling for,
even though it's a sort of a left wing
movement.
They're asking for big brother,
either the college president or the
United States government to protect us
from ideas and speech and words.
Right?
So then what are we interested in?
We're interested in those people having
the power,
having more power.
That doesn't sound very left wing or
liberatory to know or radical at all.
No.
And even these ideas,
I mean,
to stray slightly from this,
when,
when people are talking about socialism,
ideas about taxing the rich moore.
Well,
where the fuck do you think that money's
going?
Exactly.
Can I go to the government going to
Bernie Sanders?
Yeah.
Well,
when Bernie Sanders says that,
I'm like,
Bernie,
do you,
are you,
you,
you're a senator.
You understand where this money goes to
him as,
I mean,
it goes to him to control.
Well,
it's the idea behind you take more money
from people and give to the government
to make things even that is fucking
crazy talk.
That's not how it works.
If you want to encourage charitable
donations on a wide scale and encourage
some sort of like broad range
philanthropists from uh,
amongst people and figure out some way
to institute that voluntarily,
that's great.
But,
but Joe,
we all know that when you give the
government lots of money,
it uses it wisely.
Oh,
that's true.
I forgot.
And it doesn't ever use the money to
hurt anyone.
No,
never know that.
And they never wasted.
You're being silly.
Yeah,
I'm right.
But that actually is sort of this,
that is,
I mean,
it is that absurd.
that's the assumption underneath this is
that if we give them more money,
they're going to do nice things with it.
They're going to feed orphans with it.
I had a friend.
No,
actually they're going to drop bombs on
orphans 100%.
I mean,
you can look,
either you don't get a,
um,
like a,
an itemized sheet of where your money
when like phone bombs,
I'm all for that.
Itemized taxes.
Yeah,
it'd be amazing.
Would it be amazing to,
if we can link it up online where
everybody could take your itemized tax
sheets and say,
okay,
let's just make sure that they used all
of our money.
Everybody submit your itemized tax
sheets so we can show we're all,
we're missing $1 billion.
How weird where?
How Fun would that be?
Be like Afghanistan?
No.
Yeah.
Well we don't even have any idea where
our money goes.
It's one of the weirdest things cause
you give a significant percentage if you
make more than,
what is it?
$250,000 a year.
You pay 40% plus in taxes.
I think that's the number.
That's how a lot of money and you don't,
you don't even get a receipt less than
in Scandinavia.
The taxes,
how much they give them for the wealthy.
I Dunno,
but I think it bumps up against 90 in
some countries.
90 I think so.
Yeah.
90% tax.
It's around there.
Yeah.
Isn't that what Bernie wants to do?
He's a Scandinavian social democrat.
Yeah.
Where's all that money going?
The problem with that.
It's like even if you do that,
like his ideas as they've been explained
to me by people who understand the
economy,
like you'd have to charge $18 trillion
as the number.
Yeah.
You would have to tax everyone in this
country 100% of everything they make and
you still wouldn't have enough money,
right?
Yeah.
If you,
if you liquidated all the assets of all
the wealthy,
I'll all the wind percent even I think
the 2% you couldn't pay for his stuff.
They've done the math.
This is not even controversial.
Like he's even admitted this,
he's admitted this.
So what does he say he did?
They did on Bill Maher.
Actually just a few,
like a couple months ago,
he said,
well,
maybe I guess we'd have to tax the
middle class a bit to something.
Of course you would,
of course,
$18 trillion what he's calling for.
Um,
maybe it would make this society a
better society.
I mean I liked the idea of free
healthcare and maybe free education,
but then again,
when we're talking about in that case is
public education for everyone.
Public education is run by whom?
It's run by the government.
Yeah.
Do you want people need to think more
clearly about this.
Like isn't there a way to do free
education online with ads the way,
the way you have youtube ads?
Totally.
Why wouldn't you do that?
I mean as long as the ads aren't
offensive and well as long as the ads
aren't,
you know,
some ridiculous property.
That's exactly the question that should
be raised with Bernie Sanders and his
supporters.
Right?
Why?
Why do we need a government run
education system?
Why do you,
what are different way?
Why do you want that?
Because I think there's something else
going on here with them.
I don't think it's just they want free
education for everyone.
I do think they're interested in social
control and that's a great way to
control the populace is to control their
education,
right?
For the government to control their
education.
So when you say there,
they are interested in social control,
like to what extent you'd have to ask
them?
I mean,
I don't know.
Why hasn't this,
especially because every socialist has
been interested in that.
I mean,
that's,
I used to be a socialist.
I hung out with socialist.
My parents were revolutionary
socialists.
I've studied them.
How many bills did you have to pay
before you stopped being a socialist one
witness?
Which I know is when I looked at my
parents' tax returns and saw that they
made $11,000 a year in the 1970s is it?
Oh,
this is,
seems like not,
not much fun to me.
Uh,
yeah.
So yeah,
it's,
it's a,
there's a,
there's a longstanding tradition of a
desire for social control on the left.
There's nothing about that.
I mean,
the progressive's 120 years ago,
and then the hardcore socialists and the
contract deal,
the right used to be,
it would leave you alone.
That was the idea of conservatives was
that it would leave you alone,
right.
That you,
you know,
they didn't want big government.
They didn't want the government
interfering with your life.
But then it sort of got confused and
then it became,
it became a lot of religious issues
involved in the Reagan administration.
Once they started incorporating,
um,
the religious right into their,
their,
their plans,
like when they started using the
religious right in order to get into
power and to vote,
that's the things started getting really
weird because then conservativism wasn't
necessarily leave people on.
Then it became about gay rights.
It became about gay marriage and all
those other weird stuff started getting
in there.
Right.
Well,
yeah.
So the right that you're talking about,
we now call the old,
right,
because it no longer exists pretty much.
There's a little tiny magazine called
the American conservative where you can
find the old right and call themselves
Paleo conservatives now.
Paleoconservative that's hilarious.
So it's a,
that's a tiny little faction,
but they're interesting and,
and I sorta liked them at least because
they're truly conservatives,
but it used to be,
it used to be about fiscal
responsibility.
You still see it.
Yeah.
But also leaving people alone.
Right.
And then what we got was,
was the neoconservatives,
right?
And so,
well,
there's two things.
There's two.
The wing you're talking about is the
religious right.
We came along and you've summarized that
really well,
but then also the neoconservatives came
along who really were progressive's to
begin with.
And that's,
those are the people who have run the
United States into Iraq and Afghanistan
and around the world,
right?
Um,
sort of right wing intellectuals,
sort of around the Bush administration
in particular who are very aligned with
Israel and want it to protect Israel,
but also most importantly wanted to make
the world in America's image very much
committed to that vision.
Right?
And they started off as actually
progressive's or even socialists.
Right?
And if you think about it,
progressivism and socialism is
homogenizing ideology.
It's the,
you're interested in making everyone
same
equality,
right?
Right.
And if you have cultural sameness,
you will,
you will reach,
uh,
economic sameness as well.
So that's where they come from.
That's who took over the Bush
administration to make the world in the
image of the United States.
You got to invade places,
you got to send the army in to take over
and teach them how to live properly to
live like Americans.
And that's exactly what Iraq was all
about.
The Iraq war.
That's exactly what Afghanistan,
the Afghanistan occupation is about.
The textbooks being taught to Afghany
children right now were written by the
United States army.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's in the New York Times.
I mean they publish this,
I mean it's the United States Army wrote
the history textbooks that are being
used in Afghany schools right now.
Do they have historians at work for the
army for probably they hired somebody
who was willing to write the proper
history for them.
Yeah.
So then they vet it,
make sure that it fits their standard.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Uh,
I,
according to the times,
there is no mention of the Afghanistan
war in those textbooks.
What?
Yeah.
Well cause you don't want to talk about
the naughtiness,
right.
The bad stuff.
Yeah.
So I mean that's,
that's pretty naked imperialism,
right?
I mean that's what really clearly
attempting to remake the world in your
own end.
It's also super dangerous to deny
history.
Sure.
It's done.
Because then people find out the truth
and then they resent you and then become
upset and then you never trusted the
Taliban.
Yes,
exactly right.
exactly.
So right.
It's also self defeating.
Yeah.
Ultimately probably.
But for a long time they'll have some
control and they'll kill a lot of people
in the process.
So we,
we started this whole rant out trying to
figure out where this all started from,
does it,
where this social justice movement on
campus,
it's ridiculous exaggeration of
microaggressions and things along those
lines.
How much of it has to do with social
media though?
Because it seems like social media,
if they support each other and then they
find like minded groups,
they get confirmation bias.
They all join together and these little
uh,
message boards and what have you and
little twitter hashtag groups and then
they feed off of each other and then
explain to each other various things.
Yes.
I would say that just makes it louder,
but it's always been around.
I mean the stuff I'm seeing on campus
now is what I saw in the 1980s.
It's just,
it's the,
it's just that in the 1980s it could,
it didn't get off campus because there
was no twitter.
Oh,
okay.
So like this youtube video of the
students in Yale screaming at the dean,
um,
students at my college,
Antioch College in Ohio took a shit on
the desk of the president.
They broke into his office at night and
do wrong and we call them all kinds of
stuff.
You know,
we thought he was the great oppressor
cause there was no oppressor around.
So we had to create one and he was at
poor guy.
So this Occidental God that they're
trying to kick out the,
the,
the dean,
the president,
president,
what,
what do they,
what they want to replace him with
a trans black woman.
That's a great question.
Gender Queer.
And that has been raised a few times.
So who do you think you're going to get
to replace him?
Like who is there out there?
Who will be better for you?
Right.
No one,
they have at least a list of offenses
that he's committed.
Other than not having a black studies
class or program,
there's a list of demands.
You can go online and see them.
Those are demands.
They're not necessarily grievances.
It's,
it's unclear what the specific
grievances are.
Well,
and who gets to vote on these demands
too?
I mean,
is it a small tiny shell group?
Well,
the faculty has power over curricular
issues and then administrative issues or
the president in his office as basically
okay.
Um,
it,
it's sort of embarrassing to talk about
this stuff because it's so ridiculous
and I am a part of it,
you know,
I feel embarrassed to be associated with
it,
you know.
Do you remember that moment when,
um,
there was the,
the pepper spray incident on,
uh,
well,
I forget what campus,
Uc Davis.
Thanks.
Well,
they pepper sprayed those kids that were
sitting there peacefully on their knees
and they were,
they were protesting the raising of
tuition and they wouldn't leave.
So these cops,
this cop pepper sprays him in the face
and then,
uh,
after all the commotion settled,
was it the dean?
Who is that what it was the woman who
left and no one said a word as she
walked by.
It was totally eerily silent and that
was a powerful statement,
a real powerful statement.
Instead of screaming at her instead of
like,
you called the police on this,
look what's happened.
The pepper spray kids,
no one said a word and this woman walked
and she was being escorted to our car
and just dead silence.
So how do you interpret that?
It was just insanely powerful.
It was a,
there was a real,
it was like,
it was palpable.
You could see like first of all it was
shame.
The whole thing was like shameful.
Like what that cop did was shameful.
What the kids were doing was pro.
That's like a legit protest.
Like you're charging too much for
school,
you raising the rate that's a legit
protest.
And the fact that they were pepper
sprayed for doing that and by some
fucking asshole cop spraying chemicals
in the face of these kids and then this
woman leaving in total silence debt.
But that was a response to a real
situation.
Like some,
something real happen,
something real went down.
It was really like a cultural tragedy.
I mean,
he's,
microaggressions are real.
I mean,
I've,
I've seen these huge websites that sort
of document specific microaggressions
that have happened in all sorts of
campuses and I all sounds believable to
me.
I think it's all happened.
You know,
where are you from?
What are you,
what are you really that was going to be
dicky people?
Are you an athlete?
I think it's all true.
Um,
the question is how do you,
how should you feel about that?
Right?
And my war,
John mcwhorter,
his argument is by you have a choice.
He has that you have a choice,
right?
You can,
you can choose to be damaged by that.
And I think these kids really do feel
damaged by it.
Or you can think this is a parochial
knucklehead who said this,
why should I care?
Right?
What does idiot thanks.
Which is a quarters attitude,
right?
When he was at rutgers or whatever it
was,
he was just like,
he's,
and he found,
he came across some actual racists who
said things to him and he thought they
were inferior.
And he says,
that's why the what they should be
thinking now about people who say these
things,
you're an idiot.
Right?
Um,
they're,
they're making themselves damaged and
you're right.
This doesn't rise to the level of your
tuition.
Uh,
your scholarship being cut,
right?
Your financial aid being taken away.
It doesn't rise to the level of a cop
spraying you in the face with pepper
spray.
Right?
Those things are real grievances that
have to be dealt with.
I think an extreme ways.
Interesting that that was the response.
Like in a real situation,
everybody just just stayed quiet.
And this,
this eerie silence as this woman left,
right?
That was a real protest like that that
like rang out like you've watched that
video to this day and it's fucking
creepy.
Have you seen it?
Um,
I don't recall the woman walking way.
I've seen the video of the video pepper
spray.
Yeah,
the pepper spray videos.
Disturbing.
But this is really kind of powerful when
the woman's leaving and she's being
escorted out.
No one says a fucking word.
I mean,
there's a thousand people out there and
no one says a word that can be
effective,
I think.
I think it was,
that process was effective.
It was because there was a video that
went out on social media and everyone
saw it.
Right.
But I mean,
in the moment,
I think it was effective for everyone
who was there.
And I think leaving her,
I think,
I think fucking shit up as effective to
actually,
oh,
look at you.
You anarchist.
Yeah.
There's no question about it.
Would you like to fuck things up?
Well,
I think if you look at the history of
riots in this country,
you see tremendous social progress
immediately following them.
So you're pro riot.
What's that?
Uc Davis.
Um,
I am not pro riot.
I'm just,
uh,
but it sounds like it.
Well,
maybe I got to get in trouble.
I,
yeah,
I'm already in trouble.
I'm already in.
Hell No.
It's true though.
I mean if you look at sort of police
brutality,
right?
Most riots in this country have been in
response to police brutality.
And you look at the cities in which
rights have happened since the 1930s you
will see a decline in police brutality
in those cities,
almost across the board.
Almost in every case,
right?
Just in Baltimore.
Recently,
right after those riots,
those cops were indicted.
Now they may get off,
but they were indicted,
which is a rare thing for call.
Let's put the headphones on so you could
hear this
cause it's kind of crazy.
She's leaving and there's fucking
thousands of people there and no one's
saying a word or,
oh,
I do remember this.
So creepy.
Just dead quiet.
No one's talked to them.
They're protesting her.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Well she was the one that called the
cops,
right.
On these,
these students and had them pepper
sprayed in the face.
So she has this long walk of shame
and people are taking photographs,
but no one's saying a word and it's
really intense.
If you know the story behind us,
even more intense,
I mean,
this sauce for quite a while and no one
says anything and did,
did she resign or was she fired?
It's a good question.
I can't,
that would be,
that's the question to,
to answer,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
but this video got out and I'm sure this
whole scenario was brutally stressful
and it had a cost,
some form of change.
Oh,
it definitely did.
I mean,
I don't know if she suffered,
but,
but I know that Uc Davis Institute,
I think the cop was fired.
Oh yeah.
It was,
was threatened in that guy's life was
absolutely right.
And you can be sure that it's less
likely for a protester at that campus to
get pepper sprayed,
source it for just sitting there.
I mean,
that's disgusting.
You're supposed to do stuff like that
when people are dangerous and violent
and that's supposed to do stuff that the
kids are just sitting down.
But in Los Angeles it is much safer even
though it's not safe,
but it's much safer for black people,
uh,
in dealing with the cops now than it was
in the 1980s because of the 1992 riot.
There's no doubt about that.
I mean the cops,
the police,
lapd instituted wide ranging reforms and
you can ask anyone who's lived in la in
the 80s and lives here now.
It's a huge difference in the way that
the cops deal with black people in this,
in this city now.
And that was from one video,
the Rodney king video and then the trial
in the subsequent acquittal of the
officers.
And then from then what we're dealing
with is the new wave of these videos
we're seeing over and over again.
All these videos,
evidence of police brutality,
and that's probably having an effect on
it as well.
People are much more aware of what they
do and what they don't do.
There've been more indictments of cops
this year or this last year then I think
ever because of black lives matter and
social media,
there's no doubt about it.
Right.
It's very effective.
And you know,
you have Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton and Martin and molly talking
about police brutality constantly now.
And that's clearly only because of black
lives matter.
Bernie Sanders didn't want to talk about
it,
and until those kids got on the stage
with him in Seattle and shamed him and
yelled at him,
right.
And they were mocked for that too.
But they were very effective in doing
that.
And then,
so the next day,
Bernie Sanders starts talking about
police brutality and the criminal
justice system and Hillary Clinton,
like a week or two later,
it starts doing it too.
And ever since then,
they can't shut up about it.
Uh,
so it's a very effective,
disruptive protest.
They recognize that it's just up to a,
a powerful talking point.
Well,
they're forced to talk about it because
they've had these disruptive protests.
Right.
Uh,
so in that sense,
you're in favor of those kinds of
protests when I'm,
when I'm in solidarity with the cause.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's,
it's a question of tactics.
Like what does an effective tactic,
right.
And there's just no doubt that
disruptive protests and in many cases,
violent protests in the form of riots
has been very effective.
Do you think that the future involves
these kinds of institutions?
He's longstanding institutions like
Stanford and Harvard and Yale?
Or do you think that the future is going
to be something where people get their
education online more likely than not?
Well,
I think the future is the university.
I'm going to start next year.
I'm a,
I'm going to Alam it only part time,
but what I'm really doing this coming
year as launching a,
what I'm calling a renegade university,
which will be an online education set,
of course,
his lectures and interactive seminars.
For anyone who's interested in learning
about history and political philosophy,
current events,
looking at things through in a new way
and you offer degrees,
uh,
not yet.
I think most people wouldn't be
interested in that.
I think this is just for people who are
just like,
you are just curious about the world,
right?
There's a huge demand for this in the
world and it's so expensive to colleges
now.
Uh,
it's unaffordable for most people now or
many people now.
Um,
and also you have to sort of enter this
loony bin as we know,
to learn these things now.
So,
I mean,
I think people are kind of bypassing
colleges and universities more and more
through online education,
through podcasting,
through all these other media forms.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to offer sort of what I've
been teaching in my classes in colleges
for 20 years to anyone online for a tiny
fraction of the cost.
Right.
There's,
you know,
it's much cheaper to do this then for
them then to pay tuition at a Yale or
Occidental College.
Well,
that sounds excellent.
And I think we're,
we're in a unique time now where
something like that is very appealing to
people because a lot of people are
getting,
I mean,
at the end of the day,
education is information,
right?
That's what it is.
You're,
you're learning things,
you're,
you're taking in things and we're
educating ourselves constantly.
You're constantly educating yourself
with articles and books and things,
you,
documentaries that you watch.
There's always information that's coming
in.
It's just the idea is that to get an
education in air quotes,
you have to go to a place and you have
to follow their rules and you have to
sit in the class with all these other
people that are trying to do the same
and you have to somehow or another do it
together.
Right.
Why that doesn't make sense to me
because you don't live your life like
that.
You know,
your,
your life is,
doesn't involve like,
you know,
you don't go to a place and learn about
people.
You live and you learn about people.
You know,
I,
I think that it's very,
it's kind of confining and archaic to
have these,
these institutions where you have to go
there and then the whole tenure process
and the politics of the staff and the
teaching and what can and can't be in
the curriculum and who it does and
doesn't offend or appeal.
Yeah,
it's archaic.
It's actually medieval.
I mean,
the modern university is based on
colleges and universities in the mid,
in the Middle Ages,
schools in the Middle Ages.
What's the oldest running university
today in the United States?
It's Harvard.
Uh,
when was that established?
Um,
s 17th century I believe.
Wow.
I believe that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Uh,
Columbia,
the United States.
Yeah.
Wow.
What,
what the fuck was it here?
1636,
right.
Sane.
That is insane.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
It's based on schools in middle ages.
Right?
Wow.
It's truly archaic.
It's a bizarre place.
The modern college.
Yeah.
It's a bizarre,
bizarre place.
There's no other place like it.
Some of that's good.
I mean,
it's a night.
It's nice to have this space where you
can talk about ideas.
The problem is that's happening less and
less in colleges.
Isn't it good though for a lot of people
to get away from their parents,
go someplace to be around other young
kids that are experiencing this sort of
new freedom for themselves.
And then to be thrust into this is this
sort of pressure cooker of ideas.
Yeah.
But do you have to go to college to get
that?
Well,
otherwise you're stuck with your parents
and then what are you gonna do?
Are you going to get a job to pay your
rent this way?
You're in a dorm?
You know,
you're,
you know,
you show up,
Brian Bell rings go to class.
Well,
like in the 1960s,
people just went to San Francisco
instead.
Right.
And they just hung out.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
So good to San Francisco folks.
Denver's the New San Francisco.
Well,
I mean it,
yeah,
whatever it is.
I mean,
Not San Francisco now,
obviously,
but someplace San Francisco now you'll
be homeless.
If you make more than less than $200,000
a year,
you're going to be homeless.
That's not happening.
Joke either.
Now I know that place is fucking insane.
My parents just moved out of there.
Um,
yeah,
so I mean it's making less and less
sense to people.
So if you look at just economically,
you look at the price of a degree has
gone up and up and up and the value of a
degree has gone down and down and down
because everyone's got a college degree
now.
It's like the new high school diploma,
right.
As far as you returned to immediate,
able to get a job and doesn't.
Right.
Uh,
so employers are looking at degrees as
being less and less valuable.
So you know,
that's a clear bubble happening.
I mean that's a real problem
economically.
Um,
and then maybe more importantly,
there's all these other ways to learn
stuff now,
right?
Mostly online,
That's cheap or free,
either formal online courses or just
listening to podcasts or reading blogs
or you know,
are going on twitter.
I've said there's more,
and I really mean this,
there is more intellectual debate in one
hour of twitter.
Then there was a four years of college.
I mean there's far more conflict of
ideas on social media now than there is
in a college classroom because college
classrooms are dominated and have been
for decades by left liberals.
That's discourse that goes on
in there.
You don't hear conservative ideas,
you don't hear libertarian ideas,
you don't even hear some radical left
wing ideas.
It's this very narrow discourse that is
pretty much only allowed in the college
classroom.
And that's to me the most,
the biggest problem with the modern
university,
there is no diversity of ideas.
Everybody's obsessed with diversity of
color,
skin color.
But no one cares about a diversity,
diversity of ideas about real debate.
I want in my university to have a real
debate about big ideas.
I want the best minds from conservatism
and liberalism and socialism and
libertarianism to have it out too.
Let's talk about the big ideas and let's
go for it and have the best people argue
the points on their merits against each
other.
Why is it that there's such a narrow
path of ideas that exists right now in
college?
It's why is it just as tenured tenure?
Tenure?
Yeah.
I mean,
so what happened was conservatives
basically dominated colleges until the
1960s and then the 1960s generation of
radicals had nowhere to go when they
went into their twenties and thirties so
they decided to move into the academy.
So they all got phds and they became
professors and they've dominated ever
since.
There's also this system of tenure and
universities,
which is supposed to protect academic
freedom.
And what it actually does is it enforces
intellectual conformity,
right?
Because you have a lifetime appointment
and you die and you control hiring,
right?
The faculty controls hiring.
Who,
who are you going to hire?
You're going to hire somebody who agrees
with you,
who says what you think should be said.
Uh,
so that's the problem with tenure,
right?
It sort of protects academic freedom,
but mostly it enforces intellectual
conformity.
That's disturbing.
It's disturbing because you,
it's a priesthood.
Yeah.
In a way,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
You're,
you're a priest for life.
And who are you going to recruit into
the priesthood.
A true believer.
Okay.
That's what goes on in universities with
faculty hiring.
So if you have 10 year,
there's essentially no way you can get
fired on this radical crime.
You have to rape a student or you have
to be schizophrenia or,
yeah,
I mean it's almost impossible.
It seems kind of ridiculous as well
because like what if someone starts
putting out poor work?
Like A,
here's perfect example.
A guy who has tenure,
who is at the University of California
Berkeley.
I'm that guy,
um,
who,
uh,
believes that a Duesberg Peter Duesberg,
he,
I've had him on the podcast before and
it was probably the most hate I ever got
from,
but he's,
he's got this radical idea that aids is
not a,
um,
it's not a disease.
It's caused by HIV and that HIV is a
weak virus and HIV,
uh,
exist in these people because they
already have a compromised immune
system.
And that what's really going on is they
have,
um,
they,
they're taking recreational drugs and
partying and depleting their immune
system to the point where HIV can
actually show up.
And that HIV is not the cause of aids,
but it's just the symptom of a depleted
immune system.
But he's a fucking professor of biology
at the University of California,
Berkeley,
and he's widely hated by AIDS
researchers,
like people who understand HIV at a
deeper level and they think he's a
fucking moron and what he's doing is
dangerous.
But meanwhile,
he has tenure.
Right?
So let them have it out.
I mean,
he's,
he's reviled by the profession.
So what's the problem here?
Right?
I mean,
let him have it out with his opponents.
Let them,
let them argue this.
And they won't even argue with them.
No,
because it's like arguing with a
Holocaust denier.
It's like if you,
if you get on a day with a Holocaust
denier and you start debating,
I'm like,
you're,
you're giving him merit by just being
there.
And I think the market should decide.
It doesn't decide.
Right.
Meaning the students should decide.
Broadly speaking,
the students,
let's do the broad student body.
People who might go to college,
who might take his class should decide.
Right.
They don't get to decide though because
he has tenure.
That's the problem.
He removes it from market forces.
Right,
right,
right.
Whereas if the students decided,
but,
but you know,
the students are trying to get rid of
the president of Occidental for no
fucking reason at all.
The market often does things we don't
like,
but the market should be able to do that
as well.
Sure.
Yeah.
So they'll be able to kick out of what
the market is.
The market learns.
Right.
So at Occidental,
they would kick out,
if they were had their way,
they would kick out the president and he
would be replaced by someone who is just
as bad or some or worse,
someone like them or slightly better.
Or if someone that maybe they would look
out and they would find someone just
like them.
But that seems impossible because the
president of a college has to keep the
place afloat.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
So they have fiscal responsibilities.
They have taken in consideration fiscal
responsibilities.
Exactly.
What,
why was 10 you're created in the first
place.
What was the idea?
Protect academic freedom.
Right.
To allow us to say what we want in the
classroom.
Free from fear of being fired by the
administration.
And when was,
when was it an institute?
It's,
it's,
it's ancient.
That's system,
but it wasn't really fucked until the
sixties that's when,
you know,
it's always been fucked.
It's always been,
yeah.
I mean,
so you know,
in the 1920s and thirties and forties
and 50s the schools were dominated by,
it's kind of,
you know,
straight white male elites,
right.
Wealthy people.
Right.
And they had a very narrow discourse.
Two,
it was just a very different one than
we're taught now.
Right.
But they were protected from market
forces as well.
Right.
And there was no intellectual diversity
there either.
Right.
It was just as bad.
It's just a different,
it was just a different discourse.
So the problem is tenure,
the,
the heart of it,
you know,
um,
it also,
you know,
there's just this huge generation,
which I belong to have scholars with
phds who are very good teachers and very
good scholars who can't get jobs.
There's this tremendous
overproduction of phds in the last 50
years,
right?
Not Enough.
And not a lot of jobs.
We have to have more churn.
We have to have more turnover.
We have to have people.
There's all these people who are much
better than tenured professors out there
who can't teach and can't have solid,
secure jobs.
We have to eliminate tenure to make
these places better.
So because of 10 year,
you're getting people that establish
that position.
Then like here's a perfect example.
There was a,
one of the people that was talking about
the woman in Missouri that,
Oh,
was calling for muscle and Melissa
Click,
yeah,
this is their name.
W W it was this insane video.
She's telling some young man he couldn't
be there in a public place taking
photographs.
And he's like,
actually I can,
and she,
she calls for muscle to get this guy
kicked out of there.
It's just like insane.
Well,
one of the criticisms was by this guy
who is a,
a,
a professor and he said that her mistake
was that she did this before she got
tenure.
We wait until you get tenure and then
you shake things up.
Like,
no,
no.
Her mistake was saying,
can I get some muscle to take us to not
only that,
the woman,
same woman,
uh,
just a day before was calling for the
media to cover this event.
And she's,
and she's a professor of communications.
Yes.
Which is the whole thing is the whole
thing is just insane.
Right?
But it's this detachment from objective
reasoning,
this complete detachment and this,
this insistence on staying within this,
this idea that they're enforcing of safe
spaces have a intolerance to anyone with
a,
uh,
opinions other than what they're trying
to conform and what they're trying to
enforce on these kids.
I mean,
I would imagine that Melissa Click
believed that those students protesting
and the tents on that quad were being
harmed,
had been harmed and were being harmed,
were actively being oprah test by racism
on that campus and they needed to be
protected from that harm.
Now,
what actually happened on the University
of Missouri campus,
allegedly two people use the word nigger
in a six month period.
That's it.
And that's not,
it hasn't even been proven,
by the way.
Are these two people that did it well,
who no one knows.
Oh,
it's just like it's in the air to two
students claimed to know,
two students claimed that they were
called nigger.
God.
That's it.
Yeah.
With no,
no descriptions of,
you know,
and this could have happened,
it should have happened,
but no one else could have happened.
This is a part of the problem.
Kids make shit up.
Always have,
especially to enforce that victim
mentality.
Right.
So we reward victims.
Yeah.
Well that's the cultural problem.
There's a recreational victim mentality
that's going on where people are looking
for reasons why they were victims.
And uh,
in,
in that situation,
you've got a hunger strike or two people
using that word over six months.
Yeah.
And there's a hunger strike.
It's a demand to be treated like a
child.
Yeah.
It's a demand for more paternalism.
Right.
Protect me.
I'm a victim or you know,
cleanse this area of all it's impure
thoughts and reasoning.
Right.
And make it into like a playpen.
Well,
making it into a safe space.
Yeah.
Well I play then they play pens.
They Brown.
That's a bouncy house.
Yeah.
We'll at Brown.
You know about the safe spaces of Brown,
right.
University.
What have they done?
Oh,
um,
Christina Hoff summers talked about it
on,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I mean,
for everybody,
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
They created a safe space that had like
coloring books for students to go to
because of video.
If the idea is they heard were too
troubling for them.
Videos of puppies and videos of puppies,
I guess.
Yeah.
So she said these are allegations,
who knows?
But yeah,
I believe it to some extent.
Yeah.
And that was because of a woman who's a
feminist coming on to talk about the
problems with using incorrect data and
biased studies to reinforce ideas that
may or may not be true,
which she believes damage actual
feminism.
All right,
so before we continue to trash the
students too much,
I have to say this all this is true.
Everything we've said is completely true
and I agree with you on all of it.
However,
I've been teaching for 20 years for
different colleges,
elite schools,
both coasts.
This is a minority of college.
Students were talking about,
this is not most of them.
It's a vocal minors is not most of them.
In fact,
it's a fairly small minority.
Um,
most of my students,
as far as I know,
have not been like this at all.
In fact,
most of them are pretty disdainful of
this kind of stuff and just want to
learn.
Well,
I think a lot of kids today also because
of social media,
because they get to watch videos of all
this nonsense going on at Yale and all
this craziness going on in Missouri,
and they,
they get to read blogs about it and they
get to participate in conversations on
social media.
They're understanding how stupid at all
is there understanding that you're
dealing with a bunch of fucking babies.
And so there's probably some pushback in
that regard.
So what's been,
I keep saying the most troubling thing
to me,
one of the most troubling things to me
is that the faculty have been mostly
silent about this.
And it seems worse than that if the
faculty's trying to,
well,
some or some sort of mechanism summer,
some of them are egging them on,
but most I would say,
just aren't saying anything.
And I'm talking about tenured senior
faculty with lifetime job security or
not saying anything.
And I know many of them have
reservations about what's going on,
but they won't talk about it.
It's really infuriating.
Um,
and I can't quite explain it except that
they're just cowards,
but it's a terrible thing,
right?
I mean,
because the idea is these kids are
espousing,
they've gotten from the classrooms,
right?
They've gotten from these faculty,
well,
don't you want to take back your ideas
or try to teach these kids?
Isn't that what we're here for?
Yeah.
Right.
Discourse can be violent,
but that doesn't mean we should
eliminate free speech because of it.
Right.
Of course,
that intervention is not being made by
faculty though.
I'm not hearing that being said,
not publicly,
not on campuses,
but that's where it gets confusing
because if the faculty does have tenure,
wouldn't they want to express
themselves?
Like you don't have to worry about
getting fired.
Like don't you see the problems with
this kind of thinking in this kind of
enforcing this very rigid idea of what
you can and can't say or who you are and
how you behave.
But the worst thing that can happen to a
white liberal,
and I know this is to be called a
racist.
That's the worst thing that can happen
to you.
Hmm.
Maybe worse than losing your job.
Really.
Yeah.
Being called a racist and having people
believe it.
And that's,
that's a terrifying prospect for a white
liberal.
Terrifying.
So they'll do anything to avoid that
being called a sexist wouldn't be so hot
either.
But being called a racist is,
it's worse than being a sexy,
so wow.
Yeah.
Where's like trends phobic fall on that
list that's catching up.
Yeah.
That's moving up the list pretty fast.
It transphobic was weird because there's
so few transgender people,
like the,
the percentage of people that are
transgender.
It's amazing that that has caught so
much steam publicly because it's not
like you're responding to like a,
a real issue that's happening.
It's almost like,
uh,
like,
like a,
a pet thing to,
uh,
to reinforce the Trans Movement is,
is interesting.
So,
you know,
the Trans Movement started basically
after stonewall 1969,
1970s as part of the Gay Liberation
Movement.
And the thrust of that was leave us
alone and we don't care what you think
about us.
We're going to do whatever we want to
do.
We're going to dress as women are
dressed as men.
We're going to behave it however we
want.
We don't care what you think about us.
Right?
That's a very liberatory movement.
I'm a,
I'm a big fan of that,
right?
They're my heroes.
That generation,
and by the way route Paul is kind of a
descendant of them.
This is what he keeps saying over and
over again.
I don't care if you call me a she or a
he.
I don't care.
He says,
I'm going to do whatever I want to do.
Are you allowed to say he or is it she
ru Paul says he doesn't care.
He says he,
he says he doesn't hit her.
He says,
you can call me.
Either he or she.
So you can't miss gender him.
Nope.
Good for him.
He's free her.
Exactly right.G ,
G.
Zay.
So now what you see a lot,
but not entirely,
but a lot among trans people is,
you know,
they're really concerned about what you
and I think about them.
That seems to be their,
their primary concern is what we think
about them.
Again,
it's like it's asking for more
paternalism.
It's giving us more power.
Well,
asking people too,
when you meet someone immediately ask,
what are your preferred gender pronouns?
Have you seen Steven crowder
did a video?
We applied that in real life.
No,
it's fucking hilarious.
He went out,
the guys,
he something,
he went out all over the place and uh,
was asking people what their preferred
gender Pronoun would be.
The look that people gave him like in
the real world,
like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like over and over and over again.
He's asking these people what their
preferred gender Pronoun would be.
How should I refer it to you?
You know,
it just,
wouldn't it be better if we just didn't
care?
Yeah.
I mean I don't,
I think this idea that a man has a woman
inside of them and he really is a man or
a woman trapped in a man's body or a man
trapped in a woman's body and you would
like to transfer,
you know like this idea that now it's a
she or now it's a he.
I really think that you should be able
to do whatever you want to do and I
think that even if you're not a woman
trapped in a man's body,
but if you wake up one day and go,
I think it'd be cool to just get an
operation and become a woman and started
taking female hormones and see if I like
it.
You should totally be able to do that.
I'm 100% for that.
The real problem becomes when you make
whatever choices your doing,
you make it a big deal to everyone else
and you start making it so that people
have like very specific ways you're
supposed to address you and talk to you.
You change your name to Caitlyn.
Now you're kate,
you were bruce for 60 fucking years.
But now I have to make a new noise with
my face.
That means you,
and if I don't make that new noise in my
face,
I'm an asshole and I'm mis-gendering and
I'm insensitive and rude.
Well,
there is a slight possibility you might
be fucking crazy.
And uh,
if you decide that you're a Fox,
do I call you a Fox skin?
Like what?
What do I do now?
What if,
what if you do?
I mean,
people don't like those comparisons.
They don't like to,
but those are valid.
Like you,
you,
you're doing something,
you're having surgery and hormones to
become normal.
That alone should make you go,
okay,
what are we dealing with here?
What exactly are we allowed to discuss
this?
We are not.
And that's where things get tricky.
You're not allowed to discuss this and
you have to stay within a very rigid set
of rules and,
and,
and what behaviors,
you don't want to call them crazy though
to you.
Some of them are crazy.
How do you know that?
Well,
I think some people are crazy.
I would assume that there's a certain
amount of people in this world,
whether it is 1% or one 10th of 1% that
are crazy.
Now a certain amount of men who are
cisgendered heterosexual men are fucking
crazy.
A certain amount of CIS gendered
heterosexual women are fucking crazy.
You got to define crazy,
insane,
ridiculous,
preposterous.
That's been said about people who get
punched in the face for a living.
Sure.
A lot of crazy.
It's true though,
but it's true.
So my point being like when you decide
what's normal,
what's not normal,
what we have to accept and not accept
and what we're allowed to comment on.
That's when things get weird.
Like when you're,
when you're not allowed to comment on
certain things because you become
insensitive,
but you're putting
out this thing in the public,
you're making it this big social issue.
Right.
And you only have one way.
You're allowed to communicate and look
at it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would,
I really dislike is the,
as I said,
the concern for what I think about it.
Right.
Rather than you should,
you should really be free of that.
You should be free of me.
Yeah,
but that seemed to be con entirely
concerned with what I think and what I
say.
Yes.
Again,
this is a repudiation of the 1960s and
Seventies Gay Liberation Movement and
the Trans Liberation Movement of that
time,
that the whole point of that movement
was,
we don't care what you think about us.
We're going to fucking the streets.
We're going to be naked,
we're going to dress however we want.
We're going to act however we want.
We don't care.
That was true freedom.
Now it's,
it's about wanting to be treated
properly by parents,
by making us into their parents.
Well,
it's also sort of reinforcing this new
society standards of acceptance,
which I'm 100% in favor of the idea
that,
you know,
it is okay if your dad just decided to
become a woman at 60 years old and
starts wearing dresses.
If it makes him feel better,
which I'm 100% for,
right?
But why shouldn't,
I mean I'm,
I'm a big believer in choice.
I'm a big believer what's all being
different and I wouldn't be in the
business of calling people crazy.
Well that's because you're a professor.
You're not a comedian.
I'm,
I'm in the business of calling people
crazy,
but I think they're crazy.
Well,
it just doesn't mean a lot crazy.
Doesn't mean a lot.
And it doesn't my world because it's so
arbitrary.
Right?
Yeah.
It's been applied to certainly everyone.
I certainly,
I'm sure you've been called crazy.
I've been called crazy.
Everyone's been crazily crazy.
Yeah.
Well it depends on your standard.
But,
but so you really want to allow people
to do whatever they want.
Certainly then don't call them crazy.
Why does that have any effect on whether
or not they do whatever I want?
Not saying it's stopping some of my
favorite people doing whatever they want
or fucking public that you want to
encourage people to do whatever they
want.
Um,
I do,
but I don't think that calling someone
crazy for crazy behavior stops that.
And if it does,
then maybe you're not free enough.
Yeah.
I,
again,
they should not care too much about
what,
that's my main point here,
but if you're really in favor of making
people feel free to make whatever
choices they want,
then using terms like insane and crazy
is not helpful.
Well,
I could see that point,
but also there's,
there's a very real possibility that
people with all sorts of dysmorphia
issues,
whether it is a Anorexia,
whether it's bodybuilder dysmorphia,
where they never can be big enough that
all of these are,
these are conditions that are
psychological,
mental conditions that you could say
this person's crazy.
Like when you see a bodybuilder and they
can't stop getting bigger because
they're out of their mind,
they look at themselves in the mirror
and they think they're tiny and so that
there are 350 fucking pounds and they're
doing steroids and lifting weights 24
hours a day.
You can say,
that guy's crazy,
right?
No,
what
you can,
okay,
you're in this weird pc area now that
you have kind of accepted because you go
to school and you teach and you're a
part of it now,
but that's a crazy person we're doing.
We're talking about a man who's a
bodybuilder who lifts so much weight so
that his body is like virtually
exploding and they,
they have a dysmorphia where they cover
themselves up because they always look
tiny.
You don't think that there's a
psychological condition there?
There's a psychological condition.
Doesn't that make you crazy?
Um,
what,
what does crazy mean?
I don't,
I mean,
ah,
we're good.
And again,
Mantis here doing Jujitsu is called
crazy.
You know,
I mean it's being a professor has been
called crazy.
Sure.
So why,
why do you have issue with the word
crazy then?
Because you're pathologizing people's
choices.
You're saying I'm pathologizing people's
If they lift weights until their body
explodes.
I knew a dude who,
uh,
who literally did that.
He,
he was a bodybuilder and he died,
I think he was like 31 or 32.
We used to call them garden hoses cause
his arms had veins that were like garden
hoses.
There were these giant,
I mean,
it was insane.
You looked at them,
you'd never seen a human being like him.
He would lift weights.
He was a white guy.
Like is,
why did you he would turn fucking
purple.
I mean purple.
He was just 80% steroids.
His body was just overrun.
He was out of his mind.
He was definitely crazy.
Would you call that guy crazy?
No.
He lifted weights until he died.
You don't think that's crazy.
What about martial artists do not use
crazy at all?
Is that what's going on on a martial
artist?
He was crazy.
Do you use the term crazy?
I try not to.
What's a school shooter?
Is that a crazy person?
It's someone I want to avoid.
Not Crazy.
Huh?
Do you limit speech and your own mind?
Are you limiting your own speech?
Censoring myself all the time.
A little bit with what?
The word crazy.
You have a problem with the word crazy.
Do why?
I do I?
As I said,
I think it pathologizes people's
choices.
I think it contributes to a limitation
of freedom.
Crazy contributes a limitation for you
and it's been used against all sorts of
behaviors that you would absolutely
consider to be normal now.
Right.
But I don't,
it doesn't affect me.
Not only that you consider normal,
but that you considered to be a
preferable,
like what behaviors?
Like I said,
like martial arts or driving a fast
sports car.
Yeah.
But it doesn't affect me in a negative
way.
Like if you say that I'm crazy because I
like to do stand up when I'm high,
like that's,
that's not,
that's not gonna affect me.
Well,
Eh,
well it's in a way your infant towel,
your infant [inaudible] that's on the
word.
Infantilizing infantilizing um,
people that you would use that moniker
on.
Well,
what do you gain from calling someone
crazy?
It's fun.
Oh,
okay.
That's fine.
I like calling.
I'm not,
what do you gain by any adjective?
The question is what you wanted,
what you want to accomplish.
So I'm not moralizing against you using
that term.
Go ahead.
But if you're interested in human
freedom,
right.
And encouraging him
and freedom than I would discourage
using the term crazy to describe
people's choices.
Wow.
That's,
but,
but I use it all the time and I'm in
favor of people's freedom and I think
he's crazy and he's awesome.
Like,
is that okay?
It's not about being okay or not.
Okay.
I'm just saying again,
it's about objectives.
What is your objective?
If it's maximizing human freedom,
that's the word that doesn't reach that
objective.
Well,
the idea behind that would be then
somehow or another,
the word crazy would have a negative
impact on the person that you,
you use it on what you're doing by
saying something as crazy as you're
saying.
They should not do this thing.
No,
not at all.
No.
I thought you were.
Oh,
about the bustle of the muscle.
The bodybuilder.
I don't give a fuck if he lifts himself
to death.
It was my kid.
I'd probably try to get them help.
Okay.
Well,
but it's obviously it's used,
you admit it's usually it's used in that
way though.
It's used as a negative.
Right.
Usually it's you're saying you should
not do that.
That's a bad thing to do.
You should not ride a motorcycle without
a helmet.
That's crazy.
It is.
But you're going to die anyway,
you know?
I mean,
I then I'm,
the way I view crazy is there's broad
ranges of crazy,
right?
Like there's the crazy guy that walks in
the street talking to himself and he's
not on a Bluetooth headset.
He's just,
you know,
having internal dialogues externally,
that guy,
that's crazy person,
right?
Yeah.
It's not crazy person.
Okay.
What is that?
So it's very dangerous because people
have been locked up,
right.
For behaviors that were called crazy
that you would never consider to be
crazy now.
Right?
Right.
Against their will.
All kinds of behaviors have been
punished harshly,
right.
Because they were deemed to be crazy or
insane.
Right.
Or pathological.
So I,
I,
you can do whatever you want,
but I don't want to be in the business
of labeling things,
behaviors,
choices,
other people's choices as those things,
because I know where I can lead them,
they can lead them to lock up.
Well,
I think there's a,
we're,
we're dealing with a broad definition of
the word crazy.
And some of them are pejorative and some
of them that are actually positive.
And there's a lot of people that I find
to be crazy that I enjoy very much.
And there was some of my favorite
people.
It's also utterly arbitrary,
right?
So it becomes basically meaningless
isn't necessarily your crazy is someone
else's normal?
Well,
if you watch a guy and he's walking a
tight rope in between two buildings,
a hundred stories up,
that guy's fucking crazy.
I'm not saying that he should go to jail
or anyone wants to stop his choices,
but that is a fucking crazy thing to do
is I don't know.
What does that mean though?
What do you think?
We're playing games here like what are
we doing here?
You,
you,
you've got on this road because,
because of the possibility that someone
who is transgender might be crazy like
this.
This should be taken into consideration
or the possibility that someone who gets
their face tattoo definition
pathologizing something by calling it
crazy.
You're saying that it's not normal it
and basically you're suggesting at least
suggesting or just straight out saying
that it should not be done on a tight
rope.
You shouldn't dress on.
She shouldn't dress as a woman.
You should do whatever you want.
Okay.
I a hundred percent think that you
should.
If you really want to lift yourself to
death,
you should do it.
If you really want to walk on a tie rope
across two buildings,
you should do it.
What is not?
I mean,
how does one live?
Is there someone who's lived in the
world without being crazy?
That's a good point.
It sounds like a very boring place.
I'm sure there is like a very non Joe
Rogan kind of place to live in and the
non crazy place.
Don't you think maybe like a guy who
works at a deli?
Yeah.
Or just make sandwiches all,
we should all make sandwiches.
All the sandwiches are fucking crazy.
The term.
I see what you're saying.
But what if he's a trans sandwich maker?
Um,
well maybe he's crazy.
Maybe it's just crazy.
Yeah,
maybe he's crazy and a normal sandwich
guy.
Maybe he's a CIS gendered White Crazy
Sandwich Guy who hears words in his head
but doesn't respond to them.
You just don't like to work crazy.
I don't,
oh,
that's a good word.
I don't know.
I think it's a bad word.
No,
no.
Go ahead.
Give you get like a little fucking
rollercoaster ride.
You Go.
Holy Shit.
That was crazy.
Do you ever say that?
I use it all the time.
I just judge myself harshly.
I should have shame session,
you know,
by myself.
I see what you're saying though.
What you're saying is you don't want to
shame people or in any way affect our
choices and um,
you want to give them the freedom to do
whatever they want and by saying someone
might be crazy,
you're possibly limiting that.
Yes.
It's a shaming.
It could be.
It can be,
not always,
but it will also are people with like
legitimate pathologies that get involved
in all sorts of body modification things
like,
uh,
there was a guy who got his nose cut off
and uh,
he literally turned himself into the red
skull.
Is that what it is?
The Guy,
the captain America guy.
It's fucking terrifying.
He was a handsome guy,
but he had his nose cut off like the tip
of his nose cut off.
He had all these bolts put in his head.
What's wrong with that?
No,
it looks,
looks awesome.
What is wrong with that?
Is that guy crazy areas.
Look at that guy.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
he seems like a normal guy to me.
No,
he doesn't.
Is that guy came home with your
daughter,
would you do?
I'm not,
I wouldn't call him crazy because I'm
scared of him.
Oh,
because you are scared of Oh yeah.
Yeah,
because he's obviously willing to do
this to his body.
What would he do to you?
He had his eyeballs turned black with
tattoo ink.
I would certainly say it's unusual.
What he is definitely unusual.
It's possibly unique.
It's really strange.
And what's really crazy?
If you see what he looked like
beforehand and go,
who was a pretty pretty good looking
guy,
man.
Yeah.
That's him beforehand,
right?
I mean that is crazy.
And thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll give you,
where do we draw the line?
I'll give you one.
No,
I don't think it's crazy.
Oh,
you don't think it's crazy?
No kidding.
It'd be called crazy.
It's arbitrary.
It's meeting those cutoffs face dyed red
and your,
your eyeballs tattooed.
Meaningless term.
Meaningless.
It has a good meaning,
I think if you know,
if it,
if it helps sort of direct you in your
choices,
you know,
like,
or if it helps describe like a,
if that's your son and he does that and
someone says he sees that as his boy
went fucking crazy.
I'm not saying my son did that to his
face.
Right.
But I wouldn't call it crazy.
What would you call it?
Awesomely unique.
Call it.
I would call it unfortunate for me.
I look at him.
Well,
no,
because that's what he wants to do,
I guess.
Does he though?
Maybe he's just crazy
people fucking stock.
I just to stop shaking.
This'll never 30 minutes on the subject
of crazy.
Um,
I see what you're saying though.
I do.
I really do.
I mean,
seriously,
martial arts come on like crazy.
My God,
you know,
if you're going to call it 100% people,
like people call that crazy all the time
and it's why it's illegal in some
states.
Well,
I mean it's a,
it's a reason.
It's a cultural,
not really.
Well,
I know the restaurant workers,
not only that,
like martial arts aren't illegal in New
York.
You granted it's considered crazy by
much of the population and if it works.
If it were not,
it probably would be legal everywhere.
No,
that's not true.
The only reason why it's illegal in New
York state is because of corruption.
That's the only reason why.
Well,
because boxing is not illegal and
kickboxing,
it's not illegal and neither one of
those things are illegal.
Those things are brutal and violent and
they are combat sports,
so it's not the combat sports are
illegal.
It is that mixed martial arts is illegal
because of the culinary union and their
influence,
particularly on one politician who is
now going to jail most likely for the
rest of his life because of corruption
and we're hoping to be getting into
Madison Square Garden in April.
I know,
I know.
I know all this.
I do,
but if,
if all,
if the entire New York state population
thought that mixed martial arts was
totally normal,
it would be legal.
No,
that's not true because culinary again
would not have.
It's the power that it does,
but they do because a lot of the
population thinks that it's barbaric.
Oh,
I don't know that.
They didn't vote on it.
The population has never voted or they
think,
of course the much of the popular,
they haven't voted on it.
The population hasn't voted no,
but you,
you do grant that much of the population
thinks it's sparked Paris.
There's a large percentage of people
that don't like any violence,
sports,
whether it's football,
whether it's boxing,
whether it's mma.
I think it's animalistic barbaric.
It is.
And a lot of wind cock fighting.
Those guys are pussies though.
So I don't listen to this.
What I hear,
are you allowed to use the word pussy?
Oh my God,
he's Craig.
Kidding.
People are pussies within.
Not Crazy.
Wow.
Interesting.
I can't even imagine what would happen
to me if I use that on a campus.
That's true.
Calling some,
it's an interesting because pussy can be
a pejorative,
just like Dick can be a pejorative,
but a very different kind of pejorative.
Dick is a,
uh,
a forceful Pajaro.
He's a Dick.
I could sell a mean person pussy.
There's weakness.
Yes.
Right,
right.
Or it can be awesome.
Right.
I,
I've noticed that people are starting to
call women Dick's now.
Really haven't,
you know?
Yeah.
And assholes.
Assholes used to be only men.
Now it's now often women are called
asshole.
I think women have always been called
that assholes,
but not,
I don't think so.
Man gendered a lot of men are called
[inaudible] these days.
I know.
That's one of your favorites.
I love it.
Yeah,
it's a good one.
Yeah.
I mean actually,
you know,
I first heard people using cunt.
Um,
it was,
uh,
feminists actually in college really
used that for them,
uh,
for,
for other women in a negative way.
Sort of how black people.
Yeah.
It's kind of like the Nigga of like
feminists of the 1980 [inaudible] he was
really was.
That's my,
that's my country cut.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
It's kind of true actually.
Yeah.
I don't think that's done anymore.
But I remember in the 80s and at least
in my circles,
it was definitely one of my favorite
things about going to the UK is how
freely they throw that around.
I know,
but in a good way,
like,
hey,
he's a good con.
Exactly.
It's fucking con.
They love it.
They throw it around like a beach ball,
like 30 or 40 years behind the U S in
gender politics,
which may be good or bad,
but I mean,
you know,
they haven't,
they're always behind a bit.
Like I still call women girls.
It's,
that's common there.
But do you,
yeah.
Do you ever say you girlfriend where
that's not correct?
The United States.
Do you get corrected when you say my
girlfriend?
No,
but I,
I,
it's hard coming out of my mouth
considering our age.
I kinda like it and I wish I could say
girlfriend,
you can,
you can do whatever you want.
Yeah.
Come on,
man.
Freedom.
I'm trying to be on it.
I'm working on it.
I'm trying to get out.
You're my avenue out.
Am I helping you?
Oh yeah.
These kind of conversations.
Trouble.
Totally.
None of getting in trouble is good.
Right?
Because that forces you out of places
you shouldn't be in,
in the first place.
Well,
I,
I certainly think that the boxy confines
of ideas that you seem to be forced into
when you're a professor at a college,
it definitely reinforces this sort of
self censorship.
Oh yeah.
I'm always,
you have to watch yourself all the time.
That seems so exhausting.
Yeah.
I have like a standup comedian spirit.
I'm not saying I'm as funny,
but like the spirit of a comedian,
but in a professor's body.
So do you,
um,
like a range,
certain bits of humor in your,
in your curriculum,
in your courses that you teach?
Do you have like,
I mean,
in my teaching?
Sure.
I mean,
I think I,
I'm funny sometimes.
Yeah.
And I'm much freer in the classroom
cause the other professors aren't there.
Right.
But do you have to be careful of
children because it's not videotaped.
Right.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So it won't get
out.
I mean,
it could though.
You could get out.
I mean,
but only by word of mouth.
Um,
it's not gonna be on Youtube.
That's such a drag.
It's a real drag.
Yeah.
So we're going to reinvent it though.
Renegade University.
It's coming.
Do you worry about that word being kind
of Douchey?
Which one?
Renegade.
Oh,
is it Douchey?
What's a little bit us?
A little bit like almost my brand man.
I know Ben to get history of the United
States.
Your book,
my brand.
But the word renegade and like you know
you're gonna got a bunch of dudes are
sons of anarchy fan,
so shitty tee shirts.
I've seen that.
Yeah.
There's been some renegades bro.
I have noticed the Douche tinge renegade
might be careful with that word
renegades.
A tricky word.
It's,
it works for the,
for a book of renegade history of the
United States.
But as far as for a whole university,
I'll see.
I don't know,
maybe just call it crazy.
You've raised you.
Well a friend of mine suggested it
should be called fuck you.
Which I like that friends.
Probably crazy.
Yeah,
I'm sure it is.
So you look at it like it's your brand,
like the word renegade is because of the
book.
Oh yeah.
I mean the idea is I'm going to be
teaching in the university will be
influenced,
come out of the boom.
Do you feel like though that it's
possible to like limit the people that
are willing to enroll at renegade
university?
Because it just the name,
the moniker.
Oh,
perhaps that'll turn off some customers
perhaps that are looking for,
they don't like this name.
Um,
I don't mind.
It wouldn't hold me back,
but I just see there could,
it could be limiting.
Uh,
I don't know.
We'll see.
Maybe those are the people I don't want
anyway.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I know what you mean though.
It can't has like a sons of anarchy.
It's kind of got vibe a little bit.
Like,
yeah.
Somebody might be riding a harley trying
to escape from nothing.
Right,
right.
I'm a renegade,
bro.
I gotta fuck a jolly Roger Tattooed on
my ass.
I don't know.
It's just people are strange that's
trained with words,
but not crazy.
Um,
when you're formulating this university,
do you have,
uh,
like a,
a plan for launching it and for like,
how are you going to roll out courses
and are you going to,
you got to create all the courses?
Yeah,
I mean it's going to start,
uh,
with sort of standalone lectures that
you can download and listen to like
podcasts or you can watch the videos of
them.
Um,
and then if there's sufficient interest,
I'll have interactive seminars.
There's lots of great platforms for
that,
uh,
where you can,
you know,
talk to me and we can have an exchange
online and you do a chat or email with
other students.
The exact format we haven't worked out
yet.
Or are you going to have the time to do
that?
Well,
I'm gonna stop teaching and these
colleges the idea,
so the idea is to completely dedicate
all your time to this ultimate,
that's what I would like.
Wow.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And will you stay in Oregon if you do
that or were you,
uh,
I dunno.
I mean I probably do it both in Oregon
and in La.
Both go back and forth.
Yeah.
So do you have like a,
it's like a five year plan or a 10 year
plan?
Like how are you,
uh,
how you kind of rolled this out?
Who knows?
It's going to roll out next year.
If it's successful,
it could be for the rest of my life.
Wow.
I would like it to be.
And so,
um,
how are you structuring this?
Like,
do you,
do you have like a gigantic powerpoint
you've laid out or like how are you?
Um,
yeah,
I mean there'll be,
there'll be some production and there'll
be some powerpoint stuff,
graphics,
you know,
I might actually use an old school
whiteboard in the background depending
on what I'm presenting or videos and
videos.
Right.
So,
um,
be multimedia.
Yeah.
Wow.
How long have you been thinking about
those years?
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
I started becoming disaffected with
colleges and universities probably 10
years ago,
uh,
after getting fired from Barnard College
and Columbia.
Um,
and then I get fired for,
did you talk about in the last podcast
he being a white man?
Oh,
why?
Why'd you leave?
Because of my ideas.
What ideas,
um,
about is really both those reasons.
Yeah.
People just,
well,
I mean,
I'd say things you're not supposed to
say.
And My,
the renegade history stuff is,
didn't,
didn't go over well with a lot of the
professoriate and they wanted to,
they wanted a black woman also for that
job.
And then it's happened to me again at
Occidental.
I was disqualified from a tenure track
job about two years ago because of my
race.
And because of your race specifically?
That's what they said.
I was told behind the scenes.
Yes.
Hmm.
How'd they say it?
We weren't going to hire a white guy.
Wow.
So yes,
it's happened twice.
Yeah.
It's very depressing.
So depressing.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
it's,
I don't know if it's equally depressing
that they wouldn't hire a black woman.
Um,
I think it's probably more depressing.
They wouldn't hire a black woman for
whatever reason,
cause there's so many more white men
doing your job,
but it's just,
it's,
it's not much less depressing.
It's,
it's racist.
It's ways.
It's also illegal.
Yeah.
I mean,
you can't do it according to the civil
rights act of 1964 they do it all the
time.
They just do it without,
you know,
without making it public.
What is this recent trend amongst kids
where they're saying that white people
can't be racist?
It's absurd.
Excuse me.
Black people can't be racist.
Black people can't be racist towards
white people because they don't have any
power.
And that racism is imposing your own
prejudices on other people.
And this is like,
but they're,
they're trying to redefine it.
And people were saying,
check the wikipedia for the definition
of racism.
Like what?
Yeah,
so racism in its classical sense is the
belief that there are distinct and
hierarchical biological races of human
beings,
right?
Yes.
Okay.
That's racism,
right?
It's classical sense.
Right?
Then there's like prejudice and cultural
dislike and you know,
but that's um,
so anyone can be racist against anyone
else.
Right.
Um,
there is a point to be made there that
some groups have power and some don't.
So some who are racist can do things
about it,
right?
And some can't.
But of course,
black people can be racist if they think
that there are biologically distinct and
hierarchical races of human beings,
which some do.
I watched some white rapper,
they just can't put anybody in prison
about it.
And people were,
this was so frustrating as young kids
were saying,
he's woke as fuck.
Like he's woke,
he woke,
he's awake,
he's woke,
he woke as fuck.
And then people were like saying,
you know,
you're ignorant to two people that
disagreed.
Y'all need to check wikipedia.
Like what?
Check wikipedia.
This is amazing.
Like they've redefined the term racist.
They're saying white people can only,
or black people can only be prejudice.
They can't be racist.
Black people can be racist.
They just can't do much about it.
Well,
they can against,
I mean if they are an employer and they
don't want to hire a Chinese,
some blacks can veer a black guy and you
have a business.
You don't want to hire Chinese people
because you don't like Chinese.
Just as a group,
they can't do much unless they're in
South Africa where they control the
government.
Right.
10 black people can not only be racist,
but they can put you in jail if you're
the wrong race.
I just,
I'm struggling for the time to be able
to use that term.
He's woke as fuck.
The day is coming,
woke the term,
woke
all these wacky kids today telling you,
well,
I just don't understand that there's no
benefit.
And redefining the words.
Of course people can be,
they can do wrong things,
whether they're based on racial
prejudices or sociological prejudices or
economic or class,
whatever the fuck it is.
This of course there's prejudices.
You know,
why,
why redefine them like that?
Like why even waste any time.
It's just,
it seems like there's all this frivolous
bantering of,
of what should and shouldn't be used as
far as like language,
racism and sexism and homophobia are
almost meaningless now because they're
applied to almost everything.
So,
you know,
saying,
I don't like Chinese food has been
called racist.
It's not,
you can even say,
I don't like Chinese people and not
necessarily be racist.
Right.
That's just a cultural preference.
Um,
if you say Chinese people are
biologically,
naturally better at math,
that is racist.
Don't you think?
If you say,
I don't like Chinese people,
that's racist.
Not in a general the,
it's not necessarily you,
but you're generalizing about a billion
plus people.
Yeah.
Oh,
sure.
It's stupid.
I mean,
it's ignorance and it's a gross
generalization,
but it's not necessarily a belief that
they are biologically distinct.
It could be a preference.
You don't like the way they look,
they feed,
you don't wear the clothes they wear,
you know,
whatever.
I'm just,
I'm not in the jasmine.
Right,
right.
I like using fois silk,
all these silk paddler's.
What am I even saying?
Um,
yeah.
I,
it's,
we're going to have to somehow or
another get over this as a race.
We're going to have to get over
ridiculous vice president.
Yeah.
As a race.
I mean,
not as a human race.
We're going to have to get over that
origins or your ancestors and languages
that you speak and just be able to
appreciate each other for what the fuck
we are.
But how's that going to happen?
Well,
but then again,
we don't want to get rid of cultural
differences,
right?
No,
no,
that's not what I'm saying.
Yeah.
I'm saying appreciate each other for
what we are and just this idea that
people can generalize or be racist and
that,
that seems to be a counterproductive
idea that I don't understand.
It's,
it's,
it's a kin to tribalism,
which is sort of dissipating and
nationalism,
which was also sort of dissipating over
time as we integrate with all these
other cultures all throughout the world.
And you have google translate and you
can understand what people were saying
and other places.
But because of the separations of
languages and cultures and things like
that,
you're always going to have people that
are wary of people that they don't know
or understand.
I mean,
classical racism has declined
dramatically.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Last hundred years.
I mean,
until World War II,
it was dominant and respectable.
I mean,
it was taught and at Harvard and all the
Ivy League schools,
it was,
everyone talked about,
well,
how about braces?
Interracial couples like black.
Anyway,
Connie was illegal rise,
illegal for them to get married and so
many teen sixties.
Right?
And so that was all replaced after World
War II,
basically,
in,
in respectable discourse.
Not that racists went away,
but in respectable discourse,
you couldn't use the n word anymore.
Right.
Um,
and what,
what,
what road was replaced by is what we
call racial liberalism,
which is this paternalist stuff we've
been talking about that goes on in
campuses,
which was assimilationist as well.
The idea was we need to get these black
people into our institutions to train
them to become like us,
right?
It's a Brown v Board of education,
1954,
the integration supreme court decision.
That was what was said in that decision.
We need to get black people into our
schools so that we can make them into
good citizens,
good soldiers,
and good workers.
Right?
So that's what these black kids in
colleges are dealing with.
Right?
So they're not completely crazy.
They have real legitimate grievances.
They are there for two reasons.
One,
to assimilate into the dominant culture,
right?
To shed their own culture.
It's not so cool.
And to,
and this has been said,
it's very explicit to enrich the
experiences of the white students in
colleges.
That's hilarious.
That's a diversity has been stated as
its purpose.
So bringing in African students will
enrich the American students from
Nebraska.
That is the argument that has been made
explicitly for decades.
White kids benefit from being around
other cultures,
other people's,
other races.
How bizarre.
Oh yeah.
Well,
but imagine being the one black kid in
the class of 20 people or 30 people.
Right.
And knowing that you're there for that
reason,
that would make me crazy.
It'd be pissed.
It would make you pissed off.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I think that's actually the source of a
lot of the rage that's going on.
It gets expressed in all kinds of funky
ways that I'm not a fan of.
But I do think that's at the heart of a
lot of it.
Oh Wow.
That has to be acknowledged.
And a lot of the students do say this.
I mean,
they're very,
a lot of them,
most of them I think are,
are aware of that.
This tokenism that goes on and
assimilation ism and they know they're
in that class for that reason.
It's,
it's kind of disgusting.
What are your feelings on Trans Racial
people?
Oh,
like Rachel Dolezal and the the guy who
was until recently,
he was in the black lives matter and
they found that shocking.
I don't believe that actually.
I think,
I believe what I believe that his father
was black,
but his mom and his dad are both white.
Well,
the story is that his mom had an affair
with a black man.
It's only his story and unsubstantiated.
I don't know.
He was right.
He refuses to take DNA tests.
But you agreed that racism is,
fuck,
I don't think I have many times I am.
Even these,
he's got the little pencil thin mustache
in order to try to accentuate the,
but you said there's only an American
looks.
I know,
but you said there's only one human race
all,
it's all a con studies.
He's appropriating African American
culture.
Oh,
that's what I think.
That's okay too.
Right?
Well,
it's like there's been stories written
about this,
like where they've gone pretty deep into
this guy's passed and no one agrees.
Not only that he wrote on when he was a
victim of a hate crime back then.
He wrote his race as white.
Like,
that's what he wrote on the police
report.
Like you're talking about a guy like
there's,
I don't know,
just guessing.
Yeah,
we were,
we can't know and he looks white to me,
but let's say he is a Rachel Dolezal
type.
Right?
Okay.
Pretty sure.
And if race is a social construct than
their whatever,
they will be all Africans.
Even you take a pasty fine.
No,
thank you.
We're all Irish.
Pink Self.
A little Jewish.
Russian,
Russian.
Well,
Sean,
while you're African,
totally African.
Yeah.
Well everybody is.
It's where the cradle of civilization.
So Shaun King could be whatever he wants
to be.
That's what I think I,
that's what my argument was for Rachel
dolls me to spray Tan herself and
exactly do herself up in a fro.
Wasn't it amazing how you had social
justice warriors saying that she
couldn't do that,
but Caitlin Jenner,
yes.
It should be celebrated.
Yes.
That's my point.
Right.
That was my point.
Amazing.
That was an amazing moment.
It's adorable.
That contradiction.
Yeah.
Why can't you decide that you are more
properly identify with people that are
African Americans,
but do you think people would get pissed
if you appropriated the Polish culture?
Those people wouldn't give a fuck.
Yeah.
My book is full of examples going back
250 years of whites appropriating in a
celebratory way,
black culture,
loving it,
wanting to be black,
as many of them have claimed to be
black.
There was a jazz musician named Mez,
Mez Rao in the 20th century who he said,
he never said he was actually black,
but he said,
I'm renouncing my whiteness.
I'm going to be with black people.
He married a black woman,
hang out with black people all the time,
ma'am.
He said he,
I didn't want to be wide.
He only wanted to be black.
Good for him.
Mine.
Why not raise a fuck.
Yeah,
exactly.
More fun.
I just think that when you make stories
up about your past,
oh,
why don't we find out that's not true.
Well,
you've created some sort of a fantasy
narrative.
Yeah.
That's not what Mez and Ezra was doing.
He was always up front about everything.
And he was like a Jewish guy,
I think.
And he said,
no,
I'm not.
I'm just not gonna be Jewish anymore.
I was Jewish.
I'm not anymore.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
But Jewish is not really,
that's a religion.
Well,
again,
Jewish is a weird one though.
You're asking.
I mean,
right,
of course it's been defined in many
ways.
It's kind of a race and a religion and a
lot of ways,
right?
I think we talked about this last time.
So the Jews,
uh,
until World War Two were considered to
be a separate race,
very much so.
And there was a debate about whether
they were black.
Many,
many scholars thought they were black.
Wow.
Or whether they were sort of an ape sort
of missing link,
the missing link,
or they were just something else
entirely.
But they were definitely not white.
What's amazing about Jewish people is
how many European Jews have won Nobel
prizes.
How many European Jews,
brilliant scientists and mathematicians.
And that's incorrect.
It's a what?
A what an amazing gene pool.
Well,
it's in the European Jews.
I mean,
it's always been an intellectual
culture.
You know,
the rabbis and studying the texts and
the town would,
and you know what I mean?
It's always been a heady intellectual
culture.
I think that's where it comes from.
So that's most likely,
right?
Yeah.
And that's,
I think that's why they're also
overrepresented in politics in
particular radical politics.
Um,
if you look at socialism and communism
and anarchism,
it's just,
you know,
huge percentages of Jews participating.
And I think it's because they're
essentially intellectual movements.
Right?
Um,
so yeah,
no,
it's,
it's an amazing Jewish,
oh yeah.
Right.
Huge representation in standup comedy.
It's right from the beginning.
That's right.
I mean,
wasn't Lenny Bruce Jewish?
Very,
very,
the greatest of the greats.
I mean,
he was,
without him,
there would be no modern standup comedy
where I would've taken a lot longer to
develop.
It's all blacks and Jews.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not comedy.
Yeah.
Woody Allen,
mort,
Saul.
Sure.
It goes on and on,
especially that early golden era,
know that that generation was,
they would choose dominated for sure.
Yeah.
It's interesting how many of them were
involved in nightclub performing right
now.
Isn't it amazing that standup comedy is
nowhere else really in the world?
It is now.
Well,
but us just dominates.
I mean,
most standup comedy right,
is in the United States.
Well I wouldn't say that anymore.
They're a vibrant,
very vibrant elsewhere.
Melbourne,
Australia.
And they had a vibrant culture.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
Well he,
yeah,
he's,
he's uh,
I think it was from Sydney,
but um,
he might prefer from,
Oh,
where's
your outside of Sydney.
But outside of English speaking
countries there is,
it's just not as big.
Yeah.
Well America is where it started.
That's hard to explain.
Yeah.
I don't know why that is.
Cause we got the fuck away from
everybody else.
And once we got the fuck away from
everybody else who started talking shit.
So once we started talking shit,
well,
they believe that the first modern
standup comedian was actually Mark
Twain.
Mark Twain used to give these readings
and in these readings they would be very
humorous and he would essentially be
doing a monologue and it was like a
standup monologue.
And Mark Twain has some still brilliant,
insightful and resonating quotes that he
wrote hundreds of years ago.
Right.
What was this?
What year was Dwayne?
Late 19th century.
Yeah.
Or a hundred,
I should say.
More.
A little more than a hundred years.
Yeah,
a hundred plus years ago.
Um,
but brilliant,
brilliant stuff that he created back
then.
And he would go on stage in front of
these people and read these things and
they would laugh.
And so he became like a humorous
lecturer.
And that was sort of the beginning of
standup comedy,
but not Jewish Mark Twain?
Not at all.
No.
And not black.
Oh.
Although he was certainly influenced by,
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I think some other people have said that
the first standups were ex slaves.
Hmm.
I don't know.
I mean,
and Vaudeville it's hard to,
Vaudeville is happening when Mark
Twain's going on and there's lots of
comedy going on in Vaudeville and that
was Jewish and black.
I wonder what kind of speeches they
would do it.
What kind of jokes they would tell if
they would do it.
Like,
I think a lot of it was,
um,
the MCS,
like that's one of the things that Lenny
Bruce,
she's do early in the day.
He was sort of an MC for other acts.
Like you would tell a few jokes and then
bring up a band and then tell a few
jokes and bring up a dancer.
They had these variety shows,
variety shows were big deal back then.
And uh,
the MC would often be a standup comedian
and you'd be armed with jokes.
And it was like the catskills era.
It's one of the weird things is that
they had sort of street jokes and like
you would have jokes and I would,
you know,
use kind of the same jokes at you would
do.
So you would be in one place and that
would be in another place and we might
be doing the same jokes,
you know?
And then Lenny Bruce was like the guy
that started talking about life.
Whereas instead of having these jokes,
he was trying to explain why some of the
parts of our culture didn't make any
sense.
Why some of the things that we do are
preposterous.
Why there's these hypocritical aspects
of our society that should be addressed
and maybe we could live in a better,
more happy world if we kind of looked at
these more more clearly.
I think he was at first to do that.
So what we think of a standup comedy is
so broad because there's like Steven
Wright standup comedy,
which is like joke,
joke,
you know a non sequiturs not,
not connected.
And then there's George Carlin,
which is like,
he would create sort of a new monologue
every year and then he would do that new
hour on hbo,
throw it away and start all over again
the next year.
Observational humor is what you're
talking about,
right?
With some ways,
but like Jerry Seinfeld's observational,
but he doesn't have any like deep
political insight or social inside or
sexual insight.
Whereas Lenny Bruce would,
yeah.
It's like he's more restricted in his,
sir,
did you ever known us a deal?
He put a sock in the dryer where that's
all gone.
It's gone.
Like that kind of shit like that.
That's observational.
There were lenny bruce wasn't the first
political observational comedian though.
I mean,
woody Allen was doing that stuff in the
fifties he wasn't radical like Lenny
Bruce,
lenny bruce was the first radical
popular observational humorist.
I think.
Well,
the halls credit him as being the
originator.
I don't know if woody Allen was before
woody allen definitely talking about
politics in the fifties I would like to
see,
but he was talking about like the
presidential races.
It wasn't talking about daily life.
He wasn't talking about race and the way
that Lenny Bruce did doing some stuff,
some stuff that wasn't even funny.
Right?
Like one of the things that he did was
he was talking about how they,
um,
they lied when Jackie Onassis was
jumping out of the limousine after JFK
got shot or Jackie Kennedy when,
and they were,
they were saying that she was trying to
help him and that she was trying to go
for help.
Like she was,
he name was like,
she was saving her ass.
She was trying to get out of that
fucking limousine because they shot the
president in the head.
His head exploded and she jumped out of
that Limo.
And you're lying to people if you say
any differently.
And it just like this weird moment when
he was onstage.
I've heard the recordings where he's
explaining this like he's,
he's explaining like you're trying to
sell a false narrative about an
important historical event and it's
going to fuck with people's heads.
Like of course she's tried to get away.
She was trying to get away because they
just shot and killed her husband,
you know?
But that wasn't funny at all.
So there's like some stuff that he was
doing,
they like,
he just sort of like,
he had like crossed this boundary,
this weird,
strange divide into commentary that
mustn't even necessarily funny.
Yeah.
But he's flipping the script though.
I mean,
he's turning things upside down even
when he's not being funny.
Not necessarily towards the end.
All he was doing was like reporting,
you know,
towards the end when he was going crazy,
he would just go on stage with his court
transcripts and just read from his court
transcripts.
And people are like,
what the fuck is this?
It's like you watch videos of it.
I've watched them.
There is so bizarre.
He's going over finite or find details
of his court case wasn't neither last
comedian to be prosecuted for obscenity.
I think Karlyn was,
I think Carl Carlos to prosecute him.
Oh yeah.
Really?
Carla went to jail for obscenity.
Yeah,
he was arrested.
I'll,
I'll know.
I'll know how much he went through the
court system in regards to it,
but I know for sure he was arrested for
it.
Murders for our freedom.
Great.
Great Heroes.
Yeah.
Well if it wasn't for those guys
exposing how ridiculous and I mean our
culture went through this radical shift
right from the fifties,
the 60s,
sixties to seventies and they tried to
put a cork on it in the 70s and then
this sweeping psychedelic legislation
that was
passed,
uh,
in the 1970 where they,
they fucking made everything's scheduled
one and they started locking down,
um,
what you can and can't do that there was
some big giant shifts.
If you look at the shift in our culture
between 1950 and in 1980,
I mean,
what a crazy fucking 30 years.
Whereas opposed to you look at like 1980
to today,
not nearly as 85 to 2015.
What you get is more information.
You know,
you get the clothes don't look as
stupid,
but you know,
no one's wearing z cavariccis and I
don't know about that.
I mean I think there's been many
revolutions and you know,
in terms of the culture,
in terms of freedom of speech,
I think we were saying,
we're saying things we didn't say five
years ago.
Bajan lost 100%.
You know,
one of the big heroes in this,
he never gets talked about in this way
as Larry Flynt had it.
He waged many,
many successful court cases on obscenity
issues and he went all the,
all the way to the Supreme Court and he
won many of them.
And he really opened up a lot of space
for speech in the media and the,
in his seventies,
80s and 90s.
That's a very interesting point.
There's no one would,
uh,
even if they did believe that was true,
they would leave that out because he's a
pornographer,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Not Funny.
He wanted me to write the foreword to
his book.
Did you say?
No,
I did not because of who he was,
but because the book was not a good book
and I did my name associated with it.
It just wasn't not have well done book.
But what was the book about?
But I had lunch with them.
It was a fascinating experience.
Um,
it's a book about the sex scandals of
presidents.
It's,
it's not interesting.
It's stuff that's just not very
important.
Sex scandals of presidents,
like sexual secrets of the presidents.
Wasn't Nixon supposed to be gay?
They were all supposed to be gay.
Really?
A lot of them.
I mean,
that's a lots and had like a little dog
and a boyfriend.
They traveled everywhere.
Never heard of that.
Nixon being gay.
Yeah.
Never heard that.
Somebody wrote a book about it recently.
Nixon was definitely crazy.
But he was locked.
Yeah.
No,
he wasn't.
He was an unusual man,
that's for sure.
He was definitely unusual fastener into
strange castering bizarre man.
Did you ever,
um,
see hunter s Thompson's interview where
you talked about sharing a limousine
ride with Nixon because Nixon want to
talk to them about football because he
knew that a hunter was a football
fanatic.
So he's like,
he said,
no,
talk about politics at all deal.
And they said,
okay.
And they got it and they just talked
about football and Nixon apparently knew
about first,
second round draft picks and guys from
obscure colleges and Nixon was a
football fanatic and hunter and Nixon
just shared this limousine ride to the
airport and just talk nothing about
about nothing but,
but football then he definitely wasn't
gay.
I don't know.
This is when it was just a lot of gay
people that like football.
Um,
but this was when hunter was doing fear
and loathing on the campaign trail.
And so,
uh,
I don't think they understood quite the
extent of how deranged
honner was.
They took a chance with him in the
fucking limousine with the,
uh,
with the president only in the 70s.
Right.
Would that happen?
That's a total 70 story.
Yeah.
Well,
especially a president like Nixon.
He's,
he was one of the oddest presidents
ever.
Like,
it's,
it's hard to think of another man even
remotely like him.
Well,
I'm just thinking about like sort of
establishment figures mixing with
countercultural people.
You would never see that now,
right?
I don't think they kind of knew totally
how counterculture a hunter was.
Like he would show,
it's one of the things in the Gonzo fear
and loathing,
um,
the,
the life and times of hunter s Thompson,
uh,
the documentary sort of talked about how
when he decided to write that book and
he went to,
um,
the,
the campaign trail,
he was on it for a year and nobody knew
who he was,
where it's like all the politicians,
they all knew the other writers from all
these other places.
And Hunter would show up and all these
people wanted to take photos with them.
And they're like,
who is this guy's,
you know,
the astronaut or something like,
no,
nobody knew who the fuck he was.
And then some,
cause he'd already written fear and
loathing in Las Vegas and hell's angels
to hugely popular books.
But these people had no idea.
They just were so outside of that
cultural loop,
they kind of let this guy in and didn't
know who he was until it was almost too
late.
Right.
But can you imagine the Obama
administration not vetting the shit out
of someone like that?
No.
Yeah.
No,
I couldn't imagine.
I mean,
well,
I,
uh,
you know,
so what he did was he found Mark Marin.
Yes.
And went on that podcast and I,
I tweeted at mark and I said,
what George Carlin say about a standup
comedian giving a platform,
an uncritical platform to a politician
or a head of state.
And he blocked me.
He blocked too because of that.
What a pussy.
But I really,
he blocked you for that question.
Did.
Wow.
That is insane.
Fine.
I mean,
I just,
I,
I would like for him to answer the
question because it really bothered me
what bothered you.
But he did that,
that he gave this platform.
Now,
if he had brought him on and asked him
hard questions,
fine.
Right.
But he didn't,
it was clearly,
you know,
Obama,
the Obama administration found mirror
and knew that it would be safe and they
were right.
Um,
and Marin delivered for them.
He just gave him softball questions and
didn't challenge him one bit.
And basically Obama,
I don't know if you listen to it,
but just basically given like an hour
long speech,
that's all it was in Marin.
Kind of celebrated him and cheer them
on.
And I thought this is,
this is a countercultural and quotes
comedian,
right?
Doing this.
That's what countercultural comedians
do.
I thought that they challenged power.
They asked questions of power.
They made power absurd.
Like Lenny Bruce did.
Like George Carlin did.
This is like the opposite to me of what
standup comedians should do.
I don't necessarily think I would
categorize,
mark has countercultural.
Well,
no,
that,
I think he's thought of that way.
I don't think he is at all.
I think he's absolutely establishment
and conservative in that way,
but he,
I,
he's considered to
be by many to be sorta countercultural.
I always thought of him as like a guy
who like looks at himself and kind of
mocks himself and mocks but not like,
it's not like,
you know like Doug Stan hope will be
much more counter culture but also
degenerate drunk.
And the last person that Obama would sit
down with,
and if I had them on I would have to ask
him questions about drones.
I'd ask him what does it feel like to me
too to be a part of a program that has
80 plus percent depending on who you ask
innocent casualty rates.
Like what is it like to make these
decisions knowing that people are going
to die.
What is it like when you,
when you see someone like Edward Snowden
come out against the NSA's spying
platform and then you realize that on
your own campaign when the hope and
change website,
you had all these provisions in there to
protect and and help whistleblowers
whistleblowers who were exposing actual
laws that are being broken.
Like what is,
how did you make this change?
Like what is your thought process behind
that?
Like,
what do you think about a guy like
Julian assange?
What do you think about someone like
Chelsea Manning?
What do you think about someone who
delivers information to a new source and
that new source exposes things that are
absolutely crimes that the United States
public hates,
that,
that people don't ever want to think of
when they think of the American people.
Then they think of this good just um,
leader of democracy in the world.
He don't want to think about those
things.
And this is why Obama will never be in
this chair that I'm sitting in right
now.
He might,
he might take a chance.
You never know.
Just disqualified yourself.
I don't know about that because I think
those are questions that he probably has
answers to.
I don't think that he doesn't have
answers to those questions.
I think those are very,
very complicated subject.
Do you not want him being challenged in
a freewheeling way for three hours?
No Way.
That's why they chose Marin.
We'll also Marin's not live,
he's not live,
but he also worked for Air America and I
knew what his politics were.
They knew he wasn't going to challenge a
super liberal the way that you would.
Yeah.
And he sort of party line liberal,
right?
Yeah.
I guess.
I just thought,
you know,
standup comedians should never be giving
a platform to a politician.
Hmm.
I'd like to talk to Bernie Sanders.
Jimmy Kimmel did that too.
Had had obama basically made them just
look cool and hip.
I just really pisses me off.
Did you,
is that this you Ui more or less than
when Jimmy cried for the lion?
Oh,
Jimmy,
I didn't know he cried for Cecil the
lion.
We did.
He was very upset that the dentist who
he named on his television show who
legally killed that line,
by the way,
they just made lions.
Um,
they,
they put them under some endangered
species protection.
So now nobody has to worry about that
anymore.
I don't think you're allowed to be an
American.
I don't think you're allowed to go over
to Africa and kill lions anymore.
As far as I know.
I think that's the recent provision.
Americans aren't allowed to kill lions.
I'm pretty sure that's what they've,
just because there's an ancient scan,
well,
you certainly can.
Yeah.
And well not just Africans,
but people from other countries.
That's interesting.
I don't know how the law works,
but it was a,
there's a,
um,
look,
I don't think,
uh,
I think certainly that there are animals
in this world that are beautiful and
she'd be protected and I don't think you
should really kill things that you're
not going to eat.
And I don't necessarily understand why
anybody would want to go to a place like
Africa and kill a lion.
But it's incredibly complicated when you
look at the reality of what these
hunting camps are in Africa because they
have taken these animals that were on
the brink of extinction and they've made
them plentiful.
And the way they've done that is by
fencing in these enormous,
like,
you know,
100,000,
200,000 Acre areas and turn them into
these hunting preserves and they bred
these animals in there.
It's kind of fucked up.
It's canned hunting and they have areas
where these lions are free roaming like
in Zimbabwe where I'm this cecil,
the lion was killed where there's areas
where they're preserved or they're not
allowed to hunt and then areas where
they are allowed to hunt and that the
money that goes to these hunts is what
pays for conservation.
It's super,
it's super conflicted.
What do hunters need?
They need animals.
They need to conserve animals.
They are naturally necessarily
conservationists.
I mean in that sense,
yes,
Sierra club and hundreds organizations
have worked together on many,
many things for this reason,
but it just seems counter intuitive,
productive.
It seems to me shooting something that
you never planned on eating unless it's
a danger.
Like there's one thing they have to do,
like they have to shoot certain amount
of coyotes.
If they,
if I'm the cattle ranchers have calves,
they have to be very careful because the
coyotes will literally pull the calves
out of the females as they're giving
birth and kill the calves.
Like they,
they,
they have to keep them away if they want
to keep a healthy population of cows and
sheep and a lot of other animals.
That makes sense to me.
Like you have to,
you have to manage Predator populations,
but it's not what you're doing when you
fly to Africa to go shoot a lion,
you're just want to put a head on your
wall.
It's something kind of creepy about
that.
And I think that's why people responded
the way they did.
Yeah.
I mean I've never had a desire to hunt,
but I can understand,
I suppose why someone would want to do
that.
You know,
it's,
it's a spectacular thing to see at a
lion's head on your wall.
Right.
And it's a,
it's quite a trophy.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess so.
I get it.
Um,
I guess so.
I,
um,
I could see that someone would want that
or why someone would want that.
I just don't understand it.
I mean,
I know you're into eating what you kill.
Yeah.
Um,
but you do understand why,
I'm sure you understand why people get a
charge out of,
oh yeah.
Shooting a giant deer or large game
animal or,
yeah.
Well you definitely get a charge out of
it as well as get the food from it.
There's a,
there's a,
there's this gigantic experience.
It's attached to it,
but unless you wanted to eat a lion,
apparently people eat mountain lion and
it tastes good.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Mount Line is supposed to be,
I know a guy and he hunts mountain lions
all winter long.
And in Colorado they do it all legally.
He's a guide and they love mountain
lion.
I think it'd be really muscular.
They are not so good.
But so as a pig,
pigs are really muscular too,
you know?
Um,
so as,
uh,
like elk,
elk are extremely muscular.
You know,
a deer are very muscular as well,
but it's one of the reasons why they're
so lean,
you know,
it's,
um,
there's a lot of,
it's a lot of what they call,
um,
there are certain animals that people,
they just decide that you're not
supposed to hunt or eat them.
You know?
Um,
charismatic megafauna is how my friend
Steve Rinella describes some as like
bears or one of them,
but bears had been eaten by people
forever.
It's a black bear.
Especially they're,
they're very delicious and they're,
they're thought of as game animals for a
long time.
Yeah.
I was just thinking about the selective
outrage about Cecil,
right.
These lions get poached,
killed all the time in Africa,
don't they?
I mean by Africans and others.
Right.
But when some privileged white dentist
from Minnesota does it,
then it's this international outrage.
Well,
it's also because the line was named,
which was one of the more hilarious
aspects in the door and turned out he
wasn't cecil though.
No,
it was,
he sold his brother Jericho.
They were worried was killed too because
people had create this narrative that
Jericho's not going to take care of
Cecil's babies forum,
which is so fucking hilarious.
Cause first of all,
if you don't know anything about lions
and how they,
how a male becomes the head of a pride,
they murder all the cubs.
Okay.
That's a fact.
So if there are females and they're,
they're giving birth to another male's
babies,
that line will come in and murder all
those babies.
So Cecil was a baby murderer,
100% all of the heads of prides,
those are all baby murders.
So of Jericho came along.
Not only would he not protect Cecil's
babies,
he would fucking killed him with his
face.
Okay.
So they were worried that Jericho had
been killed too.
And there was a story saying that they
believe Jericho had been poached and
then they said there was a relief
because it turned out that the line that
was killed was not Jericho,
but with some other no name bitch ass
line that nobody cared about because
nobody had made a noise that you
associate with this fucking lying lying
to be a bitch ass.
I don't,
yes,
100% if he doesn't have a name.
I Dunno.
Why aren't you Jericho?
You don't even have an aim.
Jericho has got a name bitch ass lion.
Well,
um,
I don't even know how we got started on
this,
but um,
the idea was,
um,
you know,
hunting these things.
So it was Jimmy Kimmel.
That's what it was crying about it.
It's just irritating.
I'm not outraged.
I'm outraged by,
by standup comedians who have some sort
of veneer of countercultural.
I Dunno,
rebel to them.
This is really,
I didn't get some platform to the
politician is just,
I didn't listen to the Obama interview.
He didn't listen to boring.
It's not,
it's,
it sounds like a press conference or at
worse,
it sounds like a speech because there
are no questions that are any,
that are difficult for him.
I'm most offended that Mark Marin
blocked you for asking a question like
that.
Yeah.
It was pretty weak.
That's not even insulting.
Plus he's my neighbor.
Is He really?
Yeah.
We live in the same neighborhood and
yeah.
Ah,
see I'm a trader Joe's.
does he next,
you know.
Well,
I dunno.
It does now.
He better guarantee you he's going to be
getting here.
This will be upset.
Yeah.
Um,
I think for a guy like him,
it's an opportunity to just sit down
with someone who he thinks you know,
because you follow his politics.
He's very left wing.
He probably thinks is a great president.
If you look at what Obama has done,
if you look at the numbers,
what he's done economically as far as
like job creation,
as far as the rebound of the economy,
I don't understand all that stuff,
but if you look at,
it all looks fairly positive.
If you look at the raw numbers,
the raw data,
but he had very little to do with that.
With unemployment going down to 5% I
mean his policies or the Congress has
policies had very little effect on that.
What do you think that that was the
economy churning itself?
You know,
so the economy rebounding,
like do you mean the most economist I
think would agree with that,
that the fiscal policies by the
government had negligible effect on
that.
Most comms believe that exam.
Yeah.
They would say they are.
I think very few would give much of
their credit to po to government
government policies.
What about the bail out?
Wouldn't that have some sort of a
significant impact?
Yeah,
I mean it was a catastrophe.
I mean it was,
you know,
trillions to Wall Street and GM and what
did we get for it?
I mean the,
the recovery didn't happen then it took
many years after that.
It was not the plan all along was that
it was going to be a sort of a trickle
down from the,
the,
the recovery.
Yeah.
But would we have been better off if
we'd let them fail many of those things.
So I did it.
Delay,
delay the recovery,
right.
You,
you've bail out these failing
institutions that clearly are not
working well.
Would you have asked what are you going
to get?
You're going to get more failing,
right.
You know,
procedures.
Well,
once something becomes too big to fail,
that is a weird,
yeah,
right.
It's a weird state matter.
Like what does that mean?
I let them fail.
Let the market work.
Yeah.
They're worried about all these people
losing all their money had in the banks.
Just like the say.
That's what happened anyway.
Isis and the 80s but that's what I'm in
anyway.
Yeah.
A lot of people certainly did.
Right.
Yeah.
What would you have asked the president
who was there with you?
Oh my God.
I mean all the things you asked him.
Those are great questions,
but yeah.
You know,
I don't expect,
you know,
Mark Marin to be a policy wonk in a
situation like that.
But like you could ask him things like,
how do you feel,
right?
When you pull the trigger in,
you know,
drone in Yemen that ends up killing a 16
year old.
Right?
How does that feel?
How do you,
how do you reconcile your past
experience as a student activist at
Occidental College?
By the way,
I'm with now being the head of the
biggest killing machine in world
history,
you know,
how do you,
how do you reconcile your feelings as
Barry Obama who was protesting against
apartheid in South Africa with being the
president who murders Brown people in
Africa,
right?
I mean,
that's what he's doing.
So I want to know sort of personally
what in Africa and what are you
referring to?
There are,
there are troops on the ground in Africa
doing,
you know,
murdering people and there's drones in
North Africa murdering people and in the
Middle East and,
right.
So that's what he's doing.
And these are all brown people.
He's killing.
Um,
you know,
how did,
how do you feel about that or off?
Wouldn't you want to know?
Also,
I would want to know like what is it
like inside,
like what is,
what's the mechanism?
Like what's it like once you get into
office?
Like how,
how different is it than what you
thought it was when you were running?
So one of them,
yes,
I would love to get into that.
And one of the main claims it's made
about him is that he's actually a
Peacenik who's forced to do these things
by the military industrial
establishment.
Right.
Uh,
is that true?
I would ask him,
do you have any agency as president or
are you forced to make these decisions
by other people?
Right.
How do the decisions get made when you
know,
when a drone strike is made?
Is it really you and your advisors
making that decision or are you forced
to buy this thing called the military
industrial complex?
Is that true?
Is this true?
What we've been told that the president
actually has no power over foreign
policy.
I mean,
I don't think that's true,
but I'd like to hear him say that.
Right.
And if it is true that he has no power,
then what's the point of having a
president of,
of getting excited about the first black
president about getting excited about
any precedent.
If Bernie Sanders gets into office,
will he be doing the same thing then
that would be hilarious.
Wouldn't it be amazing if Bernie Sanders
got an office and just start fucking
full-scale drone attacks,
cutting down a whistle blowers and
ramped up the NSA spying program?
He probably would because he did it.
What did Obama run on?
Right?
He ran on,
I'm going to end the war in Iraq.
Uh,
and I'm going to,
you know,
be good for civil liberties and right,
I'm going to roll back all the policies
of the Bush administration was down
Guantanamo Bay,
close down Guantanamo.
And what did he do?
We actually ramped up all those
policies,
extended Bush's policies.
Now when you talk to someone like Sam
Harris,
what he believes is that Obama gets into
office ans then presented with the
reality of the ongoing situation in the
Middle East with Islamic terrorism,
with radical fundamentalists and all
across the grow the globe.
Does it mean to do America harm that
he's presented with this overwhelming
evidence that the world is way more
fucked than we're being led to believe?
Yeah.
Well that's them Harris's take.
I mean,
Sam Harris thinks the world is far more
dangerous than I do.
I mean,
he thinks that Islam is inherently
violent,
is the jihad is a necessary outgrowth of
Islam.
That if we don't take action,
lethal action against them,
that they will come and kill us.
So I don't buy that.
I know that that's his analysis.
He necessarily thinks you have to take
legal action against him.
I think lethal lethal,
lethal,
legal aside,
legal,
lethal action against him,
I think he believes that there is a,
a fundamental flaw in the ideology that
wants all people who leave the religion
killed.
And that,
uh,
that a religion that believes,
well,
a religion was founded by a warlord.
It's a different style of religion than
say like Jesus who was a Peacenik.
I don't,
I don't think he necessarily thinks that
we need to take lethal action against
them.
I think that he is more concerned about
what they are capable of doing than the
average person.
So there's no doubt that there are
Muslims who do you believe that stuff?
Right.
The question is why are they targeting
the French and the United States
specifically?
Right.
And I think that is because not,
not because of their religion entirely.
I think it's largely because France and
the United States has intervened in the
Middle East against Arabs and in France
against their own Arab and Muslim people
in discriminatory,
lethal,
murderous ways for decades.
I think it is blow back.
I think that explains why they attacked
us specifically.
Now it doesn't explain,
obviously everything those Muslims do in
the Middle East,
it doesn't explain why they insist on
women wearing burka is it doesn't
explain why they shoot gay people.
It doesn't explain why they attack other
Muslims.
But I think it does explain blow back,
I think does explain why they're
interested in attacking us and that's
what it needs to be addressed in my
view.
Right.
Stop giving them a reason to hate us.
Take that away.
If they continue to fly planes into our
buildings after we've withdrawn from the
Middle East,
then we can talk about the religion and
we can talk about them as criminals.
Psychopaths,
fine,
but that's not the case yet.
Let's remove that reason from there for
them attacking us,
then we can,
then we can see what happens.
Yeah.
Removing troops from the Middle East is
a real hot subject and I would love to
hear what the president would say about
the consequences of doing that.
The vacuum created and like what,
what's going on right now with Isis?
The,
this vacuum that has been created is now
filled up with the most dangerous
radical fundamentalist group in recent
memory.
Yeah.
I mean clearly,
I mean the big heavy weaponry that isis
is using is all American made.
It's weapons that were left by the u s
military in that region.
Right.
How fucked is up.
And what you were saying,
like they created this vacuum,
this power vacuum in that area.
Right.
Which these nut bags just easily and
quickly filled.
Well,
we're seeing that in Libya as well.
We're seeing that everywhere you get rid
of a dictator.
Exactly.
You get rid of the dictator and then
people line up to see who becomes the
next day.
It's not just getting rid of the
dictator,
it's getting rid of the government,
the structure.
Right.
Um,
there was,
there was nothing to oppose them.
Now I don't think,
I think isis is going to fall on its own
accord.
I mean,
I don't think these guys can manage a
society you've already seeing.
You're seeing evidence of people sort of
fleeing and leaving,
not because they don't like the
religion,
they just don't,
all these rules
that Isis is imposing its sharia law.
Um,
I can't imagine they could sustain a
society for very long.
Well,
it should also be pointed out that I
think something around the neighborhood
of 80 plus percent of the people that
are fighting against Isis are Muslims.
Of course.
Yeah.
And,
and almost all of their victims are
Muslim.
Yeah.
Right.
So let them,
let them hang themselves.
Is My,
my position pull out entirely?
The U s resident Thaddeus Russell has
spoken.
There you go.
Are you ready?
You ready to run?
Uh,
no.
God.
Now a couple years after you get the
renegade,
the universities,
I've been writing city up and running
and be the renegade president except
that's kind of douchey yet here renegade
president.
Yeah.
Do you have any aspirations politically?
No.
God,
no.
But you think so much about it.
Um,
I first of all,
I think I'm,
I think anyone is far more effective
outside the establishment,
right?
Um,
I think I can actually get more done and
change minds and change the culture
which ultimately influencing policies
simply by talking,
by doing this.
Right.
I think we all do that.
I think we are much,
I think you have far more power than a
congress man does.
Um,
no doubt about that.
How scary.
Oh yeah.
I mean honestly,
I mean I think that take legalization of
drugs,
right?
How fast that's happening now.
I'm not going to give you all the credit
for it,
but clearly you had something to do with
that.
I mean,
you cha,
you participated in this massive
cultural shift,
right?
I mean there were many people doing it,
but I would say that your voice was one
of the loudest and I'd,
I'd give you quite a bit of credit for
moving it as fast as it has moved is
that it's ridiculous.
I don't know if that's really,
but I dunno what,
well,
I represented very weird.
I represent the jockish guy who also is
in a psychedelic drugs.
I'm the bridge between the meat heads in
the potheads that's in that,
in that sense.
So it's got a lot more people that go,
oh,
I didn't think about it that way when
they sort of people that wanted those
two groups to be much more clearly
defined.
And I'm letting them know when it's not.
And there's a lot of benefits,
like especially like martial arts.
Like one thing that I definitely
probably done is turned a lot of people
that it would never been involved in
martial arts onto martial arts.
And just just by
talking about the benefits of it,
like praising the benefits of it.
I have seen,
I know I'm not here to kiss your ass,
but I have seen evidence of your
influence in the drug policy debate.
I've seen many people reference it.
I've seen you mentioned,
I've seen you're a prominent figure
being in favor of legalization.
That alone changes people's minds.
It's like,
Oh,
if he,
if he's for this,
maybe it's not such a crazy idea.
Right.
I really do.
I mean you're not the only one.
Of course I think other celebrities have
come out to,
but like being,
but you've been very consistent about,
he's really pushed it and I think you've
also activated your base guys who were
just into martial arts or into smoking
pot became political about this issue.
I think
in part because of you,
and I think my point is that you get a
lot more done actually by changing the
culture and the only way to change the
culture as being outside of the
establishment,
right.
Congressman can't lead cultural shifts.
Right?
Right.
And presidents certainly can't.
They have to sort of follow what the
culture dictates.
I see what you're saying.
Right.
We changed the culture.
Those guys have to do our bidding.
Well,
that's one of the things that concerns
me the most about the trends that are
going on in schools today because I
think that if you really do want to
change the culture,
would you have to change his young
people.
You have to open the eyes and the minds
of young people and to all the
possibilities and to the fact that what
our culture really is is just this
established pattern that we're all
following.
That doesn't necessarily suit you,
help you or even make sense,
but it's a,
it's got momentum behind it and it's a
habit.
The schools are a dead end.
I mean
people need to run really like deal with
this.
This fact most American children are
trained in schools run by the
government.
Okay.
What is the government going to train
those kids to be trained them to be good
American citizens?
What are they not going to introduce in
those schools as ideas?
Anything that challenges the
establishment?
Anything that challenges the status quo
in any significant way,
right?
People are sort of the cognitive
dissonance and this,
they don't ever sort of address that
fact,
which is just there,
right?
These are government schools.
What is the government going to do in
schools?
What are they going to train those kids
to do and be and how to think.
But when you say that,
like who?
Who's responsible for the curriculum?
The Sacramento in California,
State Capitol,
legislators,
politicians,
Democrats and Republicans,
but and communicators,
right?
No,
when you,
when you get a job as a public school
teacher,
the curriculum is set for you and now
with the common core,
it's,
it's set nationally.
It's a national curriculum.
No,
you don't get a choice.
I mean they sneak in there.
Certainly their ideas.
I have friends who were public high
school teachers and they sneak in their
ideas of course,
but they're not supposed to and the
curriculum is handed to them.
You're given a textbook.
This is what you're going to teach these
your lesson plans.
These are the topics,
right?
You're not going to be able to talk
about Lenny Bruce,
but you should.
Right.
So you can't have like a creative
assignment for a class.
You can't like come in and and and say,
you know what,
my job is to teach history but I want to
give these people a real perspective
only so much that you can do it on the
down low.
Sure.
Teachers Cheat of course,
but they're not supposed to and you can
get fired for it from I think Lenny
Bruce and the history of standup comedy.
It should be a central part of any
education.
I mean I think that is one of the most
important things in modern US history.
No doubt about that is it mentioned
haver.
Never.
Certainly not in the official
curriculum.
Cause those guys said bad words and they
said naughty things.
So the official curriculum,
what is the goal behind it to do,
to be the most efficient at educating
kids?
Or will you try,
you think they're trying to programs.
So the margin.
So the American public school system was
modeled after the Prussian system of the
19th century and early American
educators who founded this thing,
public schools,
Horace Mann and others said explicitly
this should be a means to train children
to be workers.
This was explicit at the time.
It was explicit.
That's disturbing.
So it's actually,
if you look at the way schools are
operated and the format of them,
it's like a factory,
right?
It's like an assembly line.
They go from this class to that class,
to that class,
get trained in this and this and this.
And then they get,
and they leave the doors and they go
work in a corporation.
That's what it's explicitly designed for
based on the PRUSSIAN system.
So I mean that's not explicit anymore
cause I would turn off a lot of people,
but that's what's being done.
They're not training them.
Why would the government trained them to
be critical intellectuals?
Why would the government train them to
think critically about everything?
No,
they can't.
The government can't.
The government has to have citizens who
are law abiding and who don't question
the,
the fundamentals of the society.
So do you specifically believe that they
set the students up and they set the
classes up in that manner?
Or do you think they do it because they
feel like that's the most efficient way
to produce the goals that they want to
achieve,
which is higher GPA,
heart,
you know,
higher sat scores.
We have to compete with China and India.
Yeah.
So it's all internalized.
I don't think anybody in the schools is
thinking what I just say,
you're not thinking [inaudible] well of
course you've got,
they've got to be good in math and
engineering cause we've got to come,
you know,
that's how you get a good job and that's
how you're a good American.
And you know,
I mean you can talk about Rosa parks now
because she's now safe because we now
live in an integrated society.
Right.
But 60 years ago you didn't talk about
her.
She was dangerous.
Right.
That had to be sort of inserted.
Um,
but now it doesn't challenge the status
quo.
It doesn't challenge sort of fundamental
ideas of the society.
Do you think they really debate
democracy and public schools?
No.
Should it be debated?
Of course.
Right.
And this is,
this is,
this is a major idea here.
Is that the platform to do it in the
high school?
Do you think,
why 90 democracy?
I know lots of lots and lots of high
school students who would love to have
that debate and are not able to in their
high school.
So what they do is they read books and
they listen to podcasts instead.
When you talk about the government
itself isn't the idea of a
representative government kind of an
archaic thing in terms of it was all
created back when communication was
incredibly difficult when you wanted a
state representative.
And one of the reasons for us,
cause like you just,
you couldn't,
no one
could get ahold of everyone in the
state.
You couldn't all get together and speak
your mind about something.
But now because of social media and the
Internet as we know it now,
forget about what the Internet is going
to be like 10 15 years from now,
which is going to be even more intense.
But you,
you could express yourself in a way now
that just wasn't available before.
You don't necessarily need a
representative government and the reason
why they have to go to these fucking
places like Iowa and,
and,
and campaign there,
and it's a big part of the campaign
trail is just because of this weird
fucking setup that they have.
Yeah.
We'll the electoral college system,
it's in the primaries to party.
Do opoly Oh yeah.
It's a mess.
It's disgusting.
It's basically a monopoly,
right,
because the two parties differ only
slightly,
very tiny amounts.
The most exciting thing that happened in
2008 was not Barack Obama.
To me,
it was a Ron Paul and Ralph Nader joined
forces with some other third party
candidates to,
to break down the rules that bar third
party candidates make it much more
difficult for third party candidates to
have a viable,
um,
campaign.
Um,
that hasn't,
I haven't seen that renewed really in
any serious way since then.
But that's what has to happen.
We don't have real choice.
You have to have real choice.
In Europe,
they have real choice.
They have parliamentary democracy where
there are many,
many parties and you have in all sorts
of parties are represented in the
legislature's.
Right.
You don't have that here.
And I think that's why we have such low
voter turnout.
Right.
If there was actual choice,
if you could actually see yourself
represented among the politicians
running,
I think many more people would vote.
Yeah.
I think there's a certain amount of
utility
people feel when they look at the two
party system and then they see where a
guy like Barack Obama arguably at least,
uh,
w with po in returns from like military
policy as as conservative as Gw
policy,
civil liberties,
state surveillance,
whistleblowers.
There's no difference and freedom of
speech,
freedom of the press,
the way they've gone after the press
and then education policy.
So this common core that I was talking
about,
this national curriculum that's now
being imposed on all the schools.
Right.
Where did that start?
The Bush administration,
it was called no child left behind is
this national curriculum,
this idea of homogenizing the culture,
the neoconservatives.
They invented that die fucking thing in
the 1960s.
It was their idea.
Irving Kristol came up with this idea.
I said,
we need to have a common core to make
all Americans similar culturally that
became no child left behind in the 19,
in,
under the Bush administration and the
two thousands.
And then what did Obama do?
He just ramped it up.
He calls it race to the top now gave it
more funding,
uh,
required schools to follow it,
more stringently punished schools for
not following it.
Now the common core is this,
this national homogenizing curriculum.
It's a catastrophe.
I mean,
the idea that a kid in key west Florida
should have the same education as my son
in Los Angeles or a kid in Mississippi.
Right?
Why?
Why shouldn't the parents in those areas
have some say over how their children
are taught?
Shouldn't there be some diversity of
ideas and cultures in the schools?
Do we all need to have the same common
culture?
I don't think so.
Well,
there's also an issue in a,
in a huge one in the way that teachers
are financially
compensated for work.
Uh,
the amount of money that teachers make
is so small and the,
the what the like the,
with the way we look at teachers,
we don't look at teachers like if you,
if you thought about someone who is
educating your child about the ways of
the world influencing them.
And we all have ideas in our head about
really positive and really negative
teacher experiences that we had as a
child.
You know,
I have a few really positive ones that
to this day I think back about this guy.
Like I had a science teacher in seventh
grade that for the first time ever
introduced in my mind the idea of
infinity.
And uh,
I'd never considered it before and he
was a really unique guy.
He,
uh,
would grow his own vegetables and bring
them in and,
and talk.
And he's really passionate ways about
what it's like to grow the food that you
actually eat.
And this is,
you know,
I was,
whenever I was 12 or something,
what are you and your yeah to seventh
grade.
I was a little kid and I was like,
what the fuck is this guy going on
about?
He was talking about what it's like to
have food that you grow,
like do to understand the actual process
of a seed becoming your food and then to
eat it and it bring it into lunch.
And you know,
and he was talking about these radishes.
It had grown in his garden that he's
eating right now.
And,
and then he was trying to explain to us
that everything in the entire world,
including human beings has essentially
made out of materials that came from a
star that exploded.
And then we were like,
what?
And then he was trying to explain that
our star is going to explode.
That we all,
there's only a certain amount of time in
every star and the sun that we,
you know,
our star w who we call our son only has
a certain amount of time.
And I remember this guy like saying this
to me,
and there are an infinite number of
stars in the galaxy as far as we know,
the Gal or the,
the the universe rather,
as far as we know,
the universe has no end.
It goes on and on.
So just stop and think about that.
How much time it would take light,
just light to get to the nearest solar
system outside of ours.
And then think about that in terms of
how big the galaxies with hundreds of
billions of stars,
each one with their own little planets
and then hundreds of billions of
galaxies.
And I remember leaving that class just
mind fucked at 12 or 13 years old and it
stuck.
Like it's stuck with me like for years,
for decades.
That one teacher,
but that wasn't,
that was him.
It was,
his idea is this wasn't,
this wasn't a part of some state
curriculum that
he had to follow.
And it was a public school,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So he's the exception,
right?
Yeah.
And there's no reason he should exist in
that system.
Right.
The system has no reason to encourage
creativity to encourage thinking outside
one's world like that,
right?
It must,
it must reinforce itself,
reinvigorate itself,
right?
The system must sustain itself.
And it does that by training new
workers,
new participants,
new citizens,
we soldiers look at it when,
when they want to justify the core
system,
how do they,
how do they promote it?
How do they,
how do they describe it?
Uh,
that it will cause the shitty schools in
Mississippi to rise to the level of the
good schools in Santa Monica and
Manhattan.
That it standardizes the curriculum.
Right?
So that the,
the argument is that kids in poor areas
get worse education and their schools,
the curriculum is not as good as in the
wealthy area.
So the standardizes,
it raises them all to the same level.
Um,
but also very much the argument was
made,
uh,
that it,
it helps us compete with India and
China.
So stem is a big part of this,
right?
So training kids to be better in stem,
um,
is a huge part of the common core.
Explain stem,
science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics.
Okay.
Right?
So if you want to build shit,
if you want to make super conductors and
computers and technology and all that
stuff that the Chinese and Indians are
doing and some people in the United
States are doing,
you have to be good at that.
So that was the argument made by Arnie
Duncan,
the secretary of education and Obama
throughout with race to the top,
we have to standardize the teaching of
stem so that we compete,
can compete with India and China does
working.
Not really.
What are the results?
I mean,
well,
it's just started.
It's just been moved out.
It's been about a year or two.
Well,
I have a friend who's got kids in public
school in Manhattan,
and he was going crazy about it.
Like what the,
the changes that it's made to their,
uh,
to what they have to study.
See,
Kay has been railing about it too.
Yeah.
The whole twitter rant about it.
His kids are in Manhattan schools,
I think.
Um,
yeah.
My son's in Santa Monica schools,
public schools,
and he's,
he's been dealing with it.
It's not.
So the common core as such is not a
terrible curriculum.
I don't think it's the worst thing in
the world.
My argument is that it shouldn't be
standardized.
Right.
I think the parents in localities should
have some decision over what is taught
to their children.
Right.
And I like cultural diversity.
I like intellectual diversity,
right?
This destroys that.
All the kids in the country will think
the same way is the,
is not that they're actually going to,
but that's what is intended with this
and it'll certainly push them toward
thinking in the same way.
It's a standardization of thinking.
It's the worst thing we can do.
Yeah.
Standardization of thinking.
Is it the idea of conformity on a mass
scale like that without leaving in any
room for creativity or any room for
exploring the possibilities of the
wonders
of the unknown of your future instead of
just trying to create a robot that can
compete with China?
Yeah,
that's what it's about.
Race to the top.
It's the name of it.
Race to the top of the world.
See,
I just,
I think the,
one of the coolest trends in this
country right now is,
is not people that are trying to do
that,
but rather people that are trying to do
their own thing.
And that what we're getting out of the
Internet is we're getting a lot more
small independent businesses where
people leave their job and say,
Hey,
I'm going to sell blank.
I'm going to make my own clock.
So I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do that,
and I'm going to find something.
I'm passionate.
And,
and,
and through the Internet there's a,
an avenue where I can pursue this as a
career where I,
you know,
dental have to join some gigantic
fucking corporation.
It'd be a cog in the wheel.
I can do something that I actually
enjoy.
Right?
And we're seeing this in like,
there's this trend in restaurants where
they want like raw wood tables and like
old style lighting and everything's sort
of rustic with metal and wood.
It's almost like this is longing for
something that's not homogenized and
pasteurized and mass produced.
Like we have this longing for things
that are,
they're crafted.
Like we,
you keep these seeing these fucking hand
crafted sandwiches.
What does that even mean?
Like you got robots making your fucking
sandwiches in some places,
I don't know about,
but that that term handcrafted cocktails
and handcraft unit,
that is a,
that that's a common thing that you hear
over and over again and it kind of
represents this desire that people have
to get away from this gigantic system of
things.
Yeah.
That's not,
that's happening outside of the school
system.
Yeah.
That's happening outside of mainstream
politics,
right?
That's happening just in the real world
that's happening among entrepreneurs
that's happening in commerce,
that's happening just in the culture
generally.
That's happening in technology that's
happening on social media where people
are pursuing happiness,
spontaneous.
It's run.
It's driven by individuals and
individual desires.
Right.
Not by standardization,
not by had a need to compete as a nation
against another nation.
Right.
It's an,
it's a beautiful thing and yeah,
you're right.
I mean there's much more of that now.
It's a great time to be an entrepreneur.
It's a great time to do your own thing,
to make a living as I'm trying to do
myself.
Right.
Doing what you're passionate about it.
I was going to bring it back to that.
Yeah.
So that's,
it's kind of unique in the sense that,
uh,
I don't know a lot of other professors
that have decided to try to separate
from the system and create their own
courses.
I don't know of any.
So you're a fucking rebel.
You're a rebel.
I haven't heard of any.
It's possible.
Maybe we should call it that instead.
Rebel university.
That might be a picture and dudes with
like American flag Bandana.
Not Good.
That is not the image I want to present.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I've been surprised.
I've been researching and I haven't been
able to find anyone who's done it.
Um,
I mean,
so there are,
there is ed ex,
there's Coursera,
there's you,
udacity.
There's these,
these,
these big moocs,
massive online
courses that are basically,
they're just in partnership with
universities.
Right.
And so they get professors in as
universities to teach these moocs.
Right.
But these people already have jobs.
They have tenure usually.
Right.
So they don't need to go independent
entirely.
Yeah.
I haven't seen anyone who's gone
independent entirely.
I mean I,
I am unusual in that I have a phd and
I've been a professor and I have a book
that's given me a fairly big public
platform.
Right.
So Mit,
they're an aren't a lot of people like
that.
There are a lot of people with phds and
there are a lot of people with big
books,
but not,
there's very few people with both those
things.
I'm going to say the thing who we're
also,
adjuncts were not actually tenured.
Right.
So I'm sorta unique in that position.
I'm going to say the thing that people
hate me when I say,
okay,
why don't you start a podcast?
I am.
See they go,
Jamie,
I am,
I only get so mad at me.
Why are you telling everybody to give
him make it her own fucking podcast?
Cause I think someone's interesting.
I think they should do a podcast.
I am.
This is,
I'm announcing this.
I would like to listen for the first
time.
Cool,
man.
Yeah,
no,
I'm going to roll that out this year to
probably say,
because Jocko sent me a text message
today.
Jocko willink is,
uh,
his podcast is live now.
The Jocko podcast just went live on
itunes,
so they go fuckers.
Yup.
Yeah.
Eric Jocko podcast.
Podcasting is exploding.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful thing.
Well,
it's the freest form of expression
available.
Oh my God.
No one can stop you from just speaking
your mind and making errors and
corrections and debating things like,
like for instance,
where in the world other than a podcast,
can you have a half hour discussion on
the word?
Crazy.
Yeah,
I know.
And,
and half joking the entire time.
I mean,
it doesn't exist anywhere else.
People don't remember or they don't know
that.
Not Very long ago there were three TV
networks.
Oh,
I remember that shit.
A handful of radio stations and about
three national newspapers and that was
it.
That's how I grew up.
And they all said the same thing.
I remember when Fox came around and
everybody was like,
what is Rupert Murdoch?
What is Rupert Murdoch as evil as he may
be?
In some ways.
He is primarily responsible for breaking
that monopoly and allowing all this
stuff to happen now.
Right.
He's,
he's the one who came in and challenged
the FCC and got that other band and
established Fox and Fox people forget,
was very,
very edgy when it started.
It's still is in some ways,
right?
If you look at,
you look at Fox programming,
it's actually,
it's far edgier than the other networks.
Right.
But he had to do that on Fox was always
thought of as literally as simpsons.
Yes.
Married with children.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
So I mean,
Murdoch gets a lot of credit for that.
The left will never say that,
but they should.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
someone can be evil and still do good.
Absolutely.
I mean,
there's a lot of disagree with many of
his politics of course.
But my God,
he did a wonderful thing for everyone.
I don't think any of them thought the
Internet was going to be what it is now.
The things,
nobody saw that comment.
Now I remember thinking,
Oh,
I'm never going to buy anything on this
thing.
Yeah.
I'm maybe I'll read New York Times on
it,
but I'm not going to actually buy
anything.
You know what I've read?
It's a staggering statistic.
39% of everything that's bought online
is bought through amazon.com yeah,
I know.
That's awesome.
Amazing.
Remember when Amazon was a failure for
years to make any,
oh yeah.
There was a joke that it should be
amazon.org because there was no profit.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
For years be Zos made not a dime.
I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure for years he made no mother
fuckers laughing.
Now when he was,
when he was only selling books and then
he started selling whatever toothpaste
and stuff and still it wasn't making
money,
and then,
I don't know,
archery products by archery releases and
arrows.
And did you hear what he's brought heads
rolling out now?
Well,
one hour delivery,
you can order something on Amazon and
get it delivered in an hour.
How is that possible?
I don't know.
They're going to set up these Amazon
outlet.
That's what they're doing.
Sprinters,
you got people with wings and their feet
and then the Amazon buttons.
You know about the Amazon buttons,
you have these like stick on buttons you
can put on.
Oh yeah.
And if you need a replacement,
as I said,
and it just automatically assuming it'll
show up in an hour,
like laundry detergent,
boom there in an hour.
Whoa.
That's bizarre.
But that seems like kind of silly
because unless there's something like
super critical that you need.
Like if this one item only like
otherwise you're going to need a bunch
of shell get out of a toothpaste button
and a fucking toilet paper button.
You know,
you don't have to have it,
but it sounds,
it's kind of weird.
Yeah,
but good.
Yeah.
Oh No,
listen,
that's great.
What I don't like about Amazon is what I
hear about the way their employees are
treated.
What I don't like about it,
as I hear about the pressure that
they're under and they have to run from
one spot to the other and deliver these
things and they're yelled at and you
know,
yeah,
it's a big high pressure factory.
I mean,
those are,
those are terrible places to work and
always have been.
Right.
But convenience.
I'm assuming they're better than the
alternatives for those people.
Otherwise they wouldn't work there.
I saw like sweatshops,
sweatshops and Vietnam are terrible
places,
but obviously they're better than the
alternatives for those people that work
in them.
Otherwise they wouldn't work in them.
It's true.
I mean it's,
they have a choice between working in a
sweatshop and being an abject poverty.
You know,
I'm not saying it's a good thing to work
in a sweatshop or an Amazon factory,
but I am saying undoubtedly it's better
than what else there is.
Whatever happened to that company that
was making phones that were supposed to
be more ethical.
Um,
what was the idea behind it?
Fairphone they call themselves a
fairphone but they fucked up and they
only had like three g and everybody's
like,
you know,
you can have no slave labor and everyone
gets paid a fine wage,
but you only get three g fuck you.
I want four g.
You can feel really good about yourself
but you won't be able to make a call.
Yeah,
you won't get any pictures quick,
but they ha there it is.
Fairphone is it still up?
Fair.
Fair trade phone fairphone to now
shipping.
Let's see the statistics and see if it
gets four g lte yet.
Cause if it doesn't they can fuck off
because it was like it was very limited.
What you're saying is that you preferred
of slaves make your phone.
No,
that's exactly what you just said.
I'm,
I'm joking.
32 gigabytes of internal storage.
You fucking clowns.
Hey,
getting by.
How are you getting by with that?
Oh,
it's a good five inch display.
Gorilla glass.
I liked that expandable storage.
Micro SD slot,
but 32 gigabyte internal.
Who's making that thing for them too?
I hope it's only fat.
Privileged white people who make them
work the fair at Yale.
At fairphone.
Okay.
I like how they got a black guy with a
brick phone.
Why?
What the fuck are you doing?
What is that point?
Why do you have that guy with a brick?
They get the black eye of brick and he's
standing in front of us.
Swamped with,
but why they give me rick from,
from a fucking rap video in the 80s
bless you.
Have that.
You're supposed to be selling these fair
phones.
Do they have good cameras too?
Was the camera say Jamie?
The statistics?
It doesn't say,
it doesn't say what the cameras out dare
they.
So I can safely say we're boycotting
this shit.
Why?
I just,
I don't know how fair it really is.
Like where are they getting their
minerals?
That's what's important because the
minerals fair trade generally is a scam.
Is it?
Yeah,
it's not really,
well,
what does it mean look fair?
Trade coffee.
Well,
all right,
here's a perfect example.
My friend owns caveman coffee and
caveman coffee is the coffee that we
have.
It is owned by a family in Columbia.
It's a single family,
single origin farm.
So when you buy it from them,
you are literally buying from the
farmers.
So like they,
they get it from the farmers,
they roast it and they sell it.
They hire all American labor and they
sell it in America.
So that's like fair trade.
Okay.
So what's unfair trade and unfair trade
is those people that live in those
places where they have the nets,
right,
that make iphones and they have to put
fucking nets around the building to keep
them from jumping off.
Like that seems unfair that they have to
live in these dormitories and that they,
they're so concerned with suicides,
they put nets all around the like
that's,
that's something that you need to fix.
Right?
So again,
like what's the alternative?
I mean,
yeah,
of course,
but like how is that going to happen?
Should we sort of impose it from
without,
should you Americans fix those factories
in China and Vietnam for them?
Or should the Chinese and Vietnamese
workers work that out?
Well,
Americans probably shouldn't get their
phones made there if the people that are
making their phones are being paid.
So then you disempower.
People want to lose their question.
But how'd they get employed in the first
place that American's create this
problem?
By going over there to the slave labor
factories and having their phones built
there instead of having a built in Ohio,
they wouldn't work in those factories if
it wasn't better than the alternative.
They're making more in those factories,
undoubtedly.
Otherwise they wouldn't be in there.
I can see that argument.
They are wood outside those factories.
But the only reason why they are making
those phones in those factories is
because they make substantially last
than someone who works in America.
Yeah.
And if you look at the conditions that
they live and work under,
their horrific capitalist development
sucks in a lot of ways.
Right.
But it's also necessary to get to
something much better.
Right.
So our ancestors worked in factories
worse than those.
Right.
But thank God they did.
Because as a society,
we advanced tremendously because of it.
So in quotes,
that is,
Russell says,
slave labor is awesome for the future.
Right?
I thought you were the one who wanted a
slave made phone.
Now that
I don't,
you want an axiom slavery.
I just think that,
uh,
I would like to fairphone sounds like an
awesome idea.
It does sound like there was another
company that had an interesting idea
too.
Then we're going to switch things out
modularly.
So like your screen could be switched
out when a new,
more improved screen came along.
They get switched out.
Your motherboard switch out on it.
It would be like different parts that it
was like a segmented sort of a phone.
And the idea being that we're doing is
incredibly wasteful.
We have this whole unit as a phone and
then we get a new one every year and a
half,
two years,
whatever the fuck it is.
And he throw the old one out and get the
whom new one.
What they're saying is no,
instead,
when they come up with new improvements,
like a new and improved camera,
you should be able to put that camera
section and take the old one out.
Put a new one in.
It sounds good.
Yeah,
we're not,
I mean they're all made by slaves,
but who's making either,
um,
what does that,
is that the,
what's it called?
Project Arra.
Google.
Oh,
okay.
Interesting.
Okay.
Ara,
project Ara.
Well,
Google is also got a new interesting
thing they're doing with their phones.
What's their flagship phone called?
Nexus with the nexus phones,
they're not,
um,
they're not constrained to a carrier.
So say if you have a nexus foam,
it'll work on sprint,
t mobile,
whoever's got the signal and then you
just pay google,
you pay Google,
whatever the fee is that they charge and
they make some sort of deals out with
all the carriers.
Is that good for us?
It's good for you if you want good
service.
Oh,
well then that's good.
Yeah.
And I like it.
Yeah,
because you're,
look,
if you're in a place where t mobile
doesn't work,
but you can get,
you know,
at and t or verizon or what have you,
you have a google phone or to work.
Yeah.
If you have one of those next nexus
friends,
any institution or organization changed
human life more dramatically than
google?
No,
I don't think so.
No.
They're nuts.
It's really crazy company for the
better.
I see.
Crazy.
In a good way.
I know that ain't good.
That's a good,
you can do that,
that's fine.
But I mean nothing is ever advanced
human existence.
No more,
uh,
broadly,
dramatically and swiftly than Google and
almost entirely for the good.
Yeah.
Almost entirely.
If you lived in the bay area,
you wouldn't know it,
right?
Cause they're the devil.
Well they're the devil because the
people that are being forced out can't
afford the homes anymore.
And you know,
I have a friend who was an executive at
Google for a long time and she just left
recently,
um,
for another
evil corporation.
But um,
when,
you know,
they would tell me how much the houses
in their neighborhood costs.
I was like,
this doesn't make any sense.
They,
there was a house in their neighborhood
that was $14 million and it was just a
fucking house.
I mean it was just a house.
It was a house.
I know is that house is in Nebraska
would cost 200 grand and it didn't make
any sense.
What are you going to do about it?
Nothing.
Right.
I mean that's what happens is so San
Francisco will no longer be a
countercultural center at all.
Not at all for sure,
nor Manhattan,
but those people will move.
But go somewhere else.
Then establish a new portland hub,
your spot Portland.
We'll actually,
that's super counter called Portland's
going to become too expensive.
And then the moved somewhere else.
Eugene.
Yeah.
Well where I'm going and Salem,
which is right down the road.
Yeah.
So I mean it just things move,
things shift,
you know?
I mean it's with San Francisco,
always a counter cultural capital.
No,
of course not.
It started in the 1960s right?
It's only for about two decades.
Was it anything important?
Those to San Francisco in New York,
losing those two,
like I had my friend Judas freelander
who was in here a couple of weeks ago
and he lives in Manhattan.
He was talking to me about how much
Manhattan has changed.
It's all just bankers.
Totally.
He's like,
it's all what?
So now the cool people are in Brooklyn
and Queens and Jersey City and you know,
they move around.
That's not a bad thing necessarily.
I mean,
why do we,
why does Manhattan have to be the place
where all the cool shit's happening?
And it's true.
It's a good way of looking at it,
but it's always has been.
So for a lot of people in the Stone Age,
as I said,
only for really just our lifetimes.
That's it.
That's a blip in history.
That's true.
It's one way of looking at it,
but it's also the,
I think in a lot of people's eyes,
especially in Manhattan,
it's being overtaken by the evil side of
our civilization.
The people that are making money by just
moving numbers around and fucking with
interest rates and dividends and yeah.
Well Wall Street is,
no,
I'm not a fan,
but partly partly because,
well,
tech,
I am a huge fan.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Google in San Francisco is an entirely
different story,
right?
Because pretty much all they're doing is
great things.
Yeah.
Tech is tech is the bright side of
prosperity and my eyes,
what's going on in San Francisco,
although all those people aren't being
pushed out of their neighborhood,
what you're getting is insane
innovation.
I mean unbelievably staggering
improvements to the quality of life for
people that are in,
here's what's missed all the time
because people talk about inequality all
the time.
Economic inequality.
It's true that there's greater
inequality now,
but it would no one talks about is that
the poor live way better than the poor
did 10 2030 50 years ago.
And that's largely because of
technology,
right.
There is not a person basically in the
United States who doesn't own a cell
phone.
That's ridiculous.
There's more cell phones than there are
people.
Yeah.
Sub Saharan Africa that,
yeah.
Sub Saharan Africa there,
I think it's a majority of people in sub
Saharan Africa own cell phones now.
Wow.
Right.
And you know,
I mean,
that's something that was unimaginable
just 10 or 20 years ago.
Right.
This incredible magical machine that the
very poor own,
right.
I mean,
that's an incredible
advance.
And the way people live,
huge numbers of poor people live in air
conditioned buildings.
They didn't in the 1960s and seventies
right.
They drive,
they own cars or they have access to
cars.
Most didn't.
Most poor people didn't until 2030 years
ago.
Right.
So it's,
Eh,
we miss this,
right?
There's this huge advance for everyone.
Yes,
it's true that the very poor are farther
from the very rich now,
but if the very poor are living better
and also by the way,
have much more access to power through
social media,
through the Internet,
through technology.
Right.
Then ever before you can be poor and
have a public voice now.
Right.
You can certainly be middle class and
have a large public voice that wasn't
possible before when there was three
networks
and this kind of balanced perspective
will be available to you at renegade
university launching in the spring of
2017 1616 yeah,
I think so.
Next year.
Well next year as a couple.
You mean like by next year?
A couple months from now,
like yeah,
like middle of next year,
2016 yeah.
Oh,
hello?
I thought you meant like a,
like a legit year.
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
2016 okay,
so what are you shooting for the summer?
Yeah,
like mid middle.
Yeah.
Nice.
Late spring.
So we come back on when it launches.
Totally work it again.
Of course.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I'd love to.
We just went through three hours.
Are you kidding me?
No,
that's incredible.
Three hours.
Great.
How do you do it?
I don't know how we do it.
We just keep doing it.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it,
man.
Thank you.
Ah,
you fall thaddeus on twitter,
Thaddeus Russell,
um,
online.
Where else are you?
Miss russell.com.
That's it.
All the information is that.
It was fun.
Really enjoyed it.
I love it.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Joey Diaz
until then.
See you soon.
Bye.
Ooh.